YOUR NOON ON THE SENATE BUDGET
AND FISCAL REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE
WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
AFTERNOON AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN REST THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WORK ON THE
PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS
TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCES THE PATIENT FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMON
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE IS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT IS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS SEVEN THREE SIX TWO EIGHT
THREE THREE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING ROOM.
AND OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE. HEARINGS HERE IN THE-
STREET BUILDING I ASK ALL
MEMBERS. HOW TO COME TO ROOM
TWENTY ONE HUNDRED I WILL NOTE
THAT- DR RICHARD PAN THE OTHER
SUB COMMITTEE MEMBER IS- BUT NOT
NOT NOT HERE TODAY. THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALSO
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. AND FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. AND EVERY
TIME YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZE
USED TO RAISE YOUR HAND FUTURE.
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS IN OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCES
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS.
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY.
PUBLIC COMMENT WILL BE HEARD
AFTER ALL DISCUSSION ITEMS HAVE
BEEN PRESENTED. BUT BEFORE WE
BEGIN LET'S HAVE THE- CHIEF. A
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. EGGMAN HERE EGGMAN IS HERE
MELENDEZ. PAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE NOTE THAT I AM THE ONLY
MEMBER PARTICIPATING TODAY- SO
WHAT WE'RE NOT VOTING ON
ANYTHING SO WE DON'T NEED TO
HAVE A QUORUM AND WE ARE GOING
TO START WITH THE DIVISION OF
COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE AND BUT
WE'RE WE'RE GONNA START I'M
SORRY. WITH DEPARTMENT OF-
COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE DEPARTMENT
OF DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES- ISSUE
NUMBER ONE IS A DIVISION OF
COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE AND
RESOLUTIONS AND I BELIEVE WE
HAVE WITH US- THAT DIRECTOR
NANCY BARGMANN AARDMAN AND-
SYRINGA WHO IS THE CHIEF DEPUTY
DIRECTOR. ERECTOR ARE YOU THERE
I SEE YOU HELLO GOOD MORNING AND
GOOD AFTERNOON. GOOD AFTERNOON
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TO YOU OUR PROPOSAL- I
AM NANCY PARSONS DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES AND FOR ISSUE ONE- JUST
A REAL QUICK OVERVIEW OF WHAT
THE PROPOSAL ENTAILS- THE
DEPARTMENT IS REQUESTING FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS AND
THEN TWENTY PERMANENT POSITIONS-
IN THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR TO
ESTABLISH A NEW DIVISION. WITHIN
OUTCOMES- WHICH THERE IS A
PORTION OF THE REQUEST THAT
WOULD BE GOING TO DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES TO- ASSIST IN
THE IMPROVEMENT OF OUR STATE
HEARING PROCESS- REALLY
APPRECIATE STAFF WORK ON ON THE-
AGENDA AS DOES A REALLY NICE-
JOB IN. WRITING THE PROPOSAL BUT
QUICKLY I JUST WANTED TO SHARE
THAT IN. ORDER FOR US TO BEST
SUPPORT FAMILY. THROUGHOUT THEIR
JOURNEY AND WORKING. IN THE
DEVELOPMENT ON. SYSTEM ACCESSING
SERVICES AND NAVIGATING IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO STAY INVOLVED AND
ENGAGED WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS
AND THOSE WHO SUPPORT THEM. SO
WE REALLY CAN'T TAKE A LOOK AT
THOSE OPPORTUNITIES TO BEST
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES
IMPROVE- HOW WE CAN ACCESS
SERVICES FOR THE INDIVIDUALS.
AND MAKE THOSE ENHANCEMENTS SO
WE CAN MAKE SURE THAT WERE
REALLY ACHIEVING WHAT WERE-
NEEDING AND WANTING TO DO AS FAR
AS SUPPORTING THOSE. INDIVIDUALS
THAT- ALL STAGES OF LIFE. THE
NEW DIVISION WHAT WOULD IT DO IT
WOULD REALLY ENABLE US TO
CENTRALIZE AND FOCUS ON
ALIGNING. THE COMPLAINTS AND
RESOLUTIONS- BUT ALSO GIVING US
AN OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY EMBRACE
THE CULTURAL LINGUISTIC
DIFFERENCES AND SENSITIVITIES
THAT THE INDIVIDUALS WE SERVE.
MAKE SURE THAT WERE EMBRACING
TRANSPARENCY AND UNDERSTANDING
THE TRENDS. THAT WE SEE AND THAT
CRITICAL AREAS OF COME. SORRY
OUTCOMES AND BRINGING FORWARD-
I'M RESOLUTIONS AND IMPLEMENTING
THE EXISTING INITIATIVES THAT
WE'VE ALREADY PRESENTED- AND
HAVE ACTION ITEMS ON FROM PRIOR-
BUDGET AX. FOUR KEY COMPONENTS
TO THIS PROPOSAL ONE IS
IMPROVING MANAGEMENT OF OUR
COMMUNITY COMPLAINTS REFORMING
OUR APPEALS AND FAIR HEARING
PROCESS. AND ENHANCING THE
DEPARTMENT'S RESOURCES FOR
QUALITY ASSURANCE OF WE CAN
REALLY FOCUS ON THOSE QUALITY
OUTCOME MEASURES. I'M FOCUSED ON
EFFORTS- REGARDING RISK
MANAGEMENT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE NOT- JUST COLLECTING DATA
BUT WE ARE REALLY TAKING TIME TO
BE ABLE TO REVIEW. AND. LOOK AT
. I START I DON'T THE TREND. THE
PLAY AND MITIGATE PLAN TO BE
ABLE TO ADDRESS. THE ROOT OF THE
WEEK ON. THE REST TO INDIVIDUALS
AND THEN LASTLY REALLY CREATING
OMBUDSPERSON OFFICE IT'S REALLY
BEEN. A GREAT EXPERIENCE OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS WITH
THAT SELF DETERMINATION
OMBUDSPERSON WHILE IT'S VERY
MUCH IN ITS INFANCY RIGHT NOW.
WE'VE ALREADY LEARNED THAT BY
HAVING AN OFFICE OR HAVING THE
AVAILABILITY OF STAFF TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE THAT IMPARTIAL- LATE TO
THE COMMUNITY IT'S DEFINITELY
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO OPEN
UP. A BROADER NOT ONLY WITHIN
SELF DETERMINATION BUT HAVE A
CENTRAL LOCATION WHERE WE CAN
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
IMPARTIAL ACCESS TO INFORMATION
THAT CAN BE READILY AVAILABLE TO
THE COMMUNITY- I DO WANT TO JUST
TAKE A SECOND SAID. THANK OUR
STAKEHOLDERS. FOR THEIR
CONTINUED ENGAGE. AND ALL THE
INPUT THAT THEY GAVE TO HELP.
AND INFORM THE KEY ELEMENTS
WITHIN THE REFORM OF THE FAIR
HEARING PROCESS. AND THEN ALSO
WITH REGIONAL CENTERS AND DGS-
THE DIRECTOR AND THE STAFF OVER
IF YOU JUST HAVE REALLY-
DEDICATE A LOT OF TIME TO- ALSO
LISTEN TO WHAT THE CONCERNS ARE
AND TO- UNDERSTAND KIND OF
PROPOSAL TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES. SO NOW- TURN IT OVER TO
AND FUTURE PATH FOR- INTERESTING
THAT OTHER QUESTIONS THAT ARE
OUTLINED IN THE AGENDA THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND WELCOME
MR SHRINK. THANK YOU FOR SHOULD
BE UP. TO BE HERE. THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S. FOCUS ON OUTCOMES
FOR THE PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
SERVING AND- AND AS THE DIRECTOR
OUTLINED THEIR MANY COMPONENT
PIECES HERE BOTH IN TERMS OF
INDIVIDUALS SYSTEMS AND
INFORMATION. BUT ALSO OVERALL
SYSTEM QUALITY ASSURANCE AND
RISK MANAGEMENT TOOK TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE. HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
DETAILED QUESTIONS- ARE SPECIFIC
TO THE ONES LISTED IN THE AGENDA
TODAY- WE MENTION OUR PROPOSAL-
WORK ON CHANGING SPECIAL
INCIDENT REPORTING- AND THAT SON
OF. A REQUIREMENT IN OUR SYSTEM
IT'S IN OUR SYSTEM FOR MANY MANY
YEARS. HI AND SPECIAL INCIDENTS
KIND OF RUN THE GAMUT OF
EVERYTHING FROM. MISSED
MEDICATION DOSES ALL THE WAY TO
FATALITIES. AS PEOPLE. AND AS
THERE'S A FAIRLY LENGTHY LIST OF
THINGS THAT ARE REQUIRED TO BE
REPORTED IN IN PART NOT BECAUSE
WE WANT TO PUNISH PEOPLE FOR
THOSE THINGS HAPPENING BUT
BECAUSE WE WANT TO LEARN FROM
THEM WHY THEY HAPPEN. AND WHAT
WE CAN DO IS A SYSTEM TO
PREVENT- AND IT HELPS US TARGET
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO. OUR
SERVICE PROVIDERS IT HELPS US
LEARN OUR OWN BEHAVIORS- INFORMS
TRAINING. AND THOSE. KINDS OF
THINGS. THE QUESTIONS WAS ASK
WHY CHANGE ARE WE CALL. HER NEXT
IT'S BEEN A FOR QUITE A FEW
YEARS AND THE CHANGES THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE OVER THOSE ALMOST-
TWENTY YEARS OR LONGER HEAVILY
BEEN INCREMENTAL. WE ARE MEETING
WITH STAKEHOLDERS. ACROSS THE
SYSTEM INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
REGIONAL CENTER SERVICE
PROVIDERS FAMILY RESOURCE
CENTERS- ADVOCATES AND OTHERS.
AND WE BASICALLY STARTED WITH A
LIST OF HERE'S WHAT WE'RE
CURRENTLY REQUIRED TO. REQUIRING
PEOPLE TO REPORT A NUMBER OF
REGIONAL CENTERS CURRENTLY
REQUIRE OTHER PEOPLE TO- SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO REPORT INCIDENTS.
BEYOND WHAT IS THE DEPARTMENT'S
REGULATIONS REQUIRE SO WE LOOKED
AT AND WHAT THOSE THINGS ARE AND
WHY THEY'RE IMPORTANT TO TRACK-
AND THEN JUST FEEDBACK FROM
EVERYBODY GENERALLY LIKE. WHAT'S
LESS IMPORTANT TO YOU WHAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT WHAT WE NOT
CAPTURING THAT WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW ABOUT IT AND IN SOME CASES.
PARTICULARLY LIKE MEDICATION
ERRORS. WHAT WHAT IS IT THAT WE
WOULD LIKE IN TERMS OF MORE
DETAIL SO TO. MAKE THAT
INFORMATION MORE USEFUL AND
ACTIONABLE FOR US. TO PROTECT
PEOPLE GOING FORWARD. WELL SO WE
DON'T HAVE A- PROPOSAL AT THIS
TIME WE'RE ENGAGED IN WHAT I
CALL THE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS
AND ADVANCES LAWMAKING WE
ANTICIPATE AT THE PRESENT TIME
THAT SOMETIME THIS FALL WILL.
WILL START- WHAT WE ESTIMATE IT
WILL BE A YEARLONG BILL MAKING
PROCESS. THAT UPDATES- ALL OF
THOSE REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AND
HOW THE REPORTED AND TIME FRAMES
SUCHER- IN THAT PROCESS TO WILL
GIVE GREAT CONSIDERATION TO OF
COURSE THE TRAINING OUT OF-
MOST. OUR OWN DEPARTMENT STAFFS
REGIONAL CENTERS AND SERVICE
PROVIDERS DOING THE REPORTING AS
WELL AS INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES
IN THE COMMUNITY SO THAT WE ARE
TRAINING ASPECT OF THAT OUT
THEY'LL BE SOME IT SYSTEM-
CHANGES ALSO TO CAPTURE. THOSE
UPDATES THAT WE MAKE- BEFORE WE
ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTED SO ALL TO
SAY IT'S A REALLY ROBUST PROCESS
WE LOVE THE COLLABORATION AND
PARTNERSHIP WE'VE GOTTEN FROM
THESE FOLKS. I WITH MANY OF THEM
WE'VE HAD MULTIPLE MEETINGS
ALREADY AND EXPECT THAT TO
CONTINUE THE BEEN REALLY
PRODUCTIVE AND I THINK EVERYBODY
AGREES AN UPDATE IS DUE- BUT
MAYBE EVEN MORE INFORMATION THAN
YOU WANTED BUT A DESCRIPTION OF.
THE CONTENT AND PROCESS AND-
ALSO THE TIME FRAME. THAT WE'RE
LOOKING OUT THERE. WITH REGARD
TO THE THIS FAIR HERE FROM. AS
THE DOOR MEANT- YOU KNOW GREAT
APPRECIATION HERE AS WELL TO OUR
STAKEHOLDER COMMUNITY FOR
IDENTIFYING ISSUES THAT NEED TO
BE RESOLVED- AND THERE'S QUITE A
LONG LIST OF THEM. I BEGINNING
AT THE TOP OF PAGE FOR YOUR
AGENDA DOES A REALLY GOOD JOB
DESCRIBING THE PROCESS THAT THE
DEPARTMENT WENT THROUGH TO LOOK
AT THIS BEGINNING IN APRIL OF.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- AND THAT'S
BECAUSE THESE CONCERNS WERE WERE
WERE RAISED SWEETENING SIX
DIFFERENT FOCUS GROUPS- ADVISORY
COMMITTEES WITH INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES SOME OF OUR COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS- SELF
ADVOCATES ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATIONS- A LONG LIST OF
THEM WE ALSO IN OCTOBER OF
TWENTY ONE- SENT OUT A SURVEY
TO. OVER SIXTEEN HUNDRED.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS THEMSELVES
ADVOCATES WHO EXPERIENCE THAT
THE HEARING PROCESS IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS AND COLLECTED
RESPONSES FROM THEM. OTHER THAN
THE THEMATIC RESULTS THAT WE GOT
BACK AS A RESULT OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND THE SURVEY.
ARE ALL THINGS THAT ARE
REFLECTED IN OUR PROPOSED A
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND THAT'S
BEFORE YOU FOR CONSIDERATION.
YOU KNOW STARTING WITH THE
BASICS- NEEDING MORE INFORMATION
AND MORE TRAINING ABOUT THE
HEARING PROCESS ITSELF AND HOW
AND WHERE TO GET ASSISTANCE. IN
NAVIGATING THAT PROCESS WELL
THAT IT'S A COMPLICATED PROCESS
SO THINKING THROUGH. POTENTIAL
SIMPLIFICATIONS FOR THAT- WHAT
WE'VE PROPOSED IS A THREE STEP.
WE CALL IT AN OVERALL APPEALS
PROCESS INCLUDING THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR INFORMAL
MEETINGS FORMAL MEDIATION AND
THEN THE HEARING AND OFFERINGS
PEOPLE THE OPPORTUNITY TO PICK.
UP ANY OF THE THREE ANY
COMBINATION OF THE THREE OR ALL
THREE. AND AFTER HAVING MADE
THAT CHOICE ALSO OFFERING THE
OPPORTUNITY IN THE PROCESS IS
THAT. THEY'RE NOT SATISFIED IN
ANY. TIME TO GO AND AMEND THEIR
CHOICE. ALWAYS SEEKING ARREST AT
THE END OF- LEVEL. AND FOR ON
FOR STICK TOGETHER TO WRESTLE.
WELL I SPOKE AS AGO ABOUT OF THE
PROCESS BEING CALM- INVOLVED TO
GO TO A FAIR HEARING PROCESS
WELL AND EVERYTHING FROM NOTICES
OF ACTION- BEING DIFFICULT TO
UNDERSTAND- TIME FRAMES BEING
TOO SHORT TO RESPOND- AND THEN
CONDUCT OF THE HEARINGS
THEMSELVES OF MANY FAMILIES FELT
IT WAS OVERLY FORMAL- AND MADE
IT KIND OF DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO
ENGAGE IN A MEANINGFUL WAY IN
THE PROCESS THAT'S SUPPOSED TO
BE THERE TO SERVE THEM- AND THEN
THINGS THAT- TO GO ALONG WITH
THAT. OF COURSE RIGHT ADEQUATE
ACCESS. IN IN TERMS OF
TRANSLATION AND INTERPRETATION
WELL FOR INFORMATION BUT AT ANY
OF THESE MEETINGS THEMSELVES.
AND OTHER THINGS LIKE THE
MECHANISM SECOND SOURCE HEARING
DECISIONS WHEN THE L. J. MAKES
THAT FINAL RULING WHAT HAPPENS
AFTER THAT AND WHAT HAPPENS.
WHAT KIND OF OPTIONS DO YOU HAVE
YES- THE DECISION IS IMPLEMENTED
IN A TIMELY MANNER SO ALL OF
THOSE TEAMS WERE RAISED ON THE
CENGAGE WENT WITH US- AND WE
HAVE PROPOSALS- IN THE TRAILER
BILL. ON ALL OF THOSE TOPICS.
WITH ANY BIG UPDATE LIKE THIS OF
COURSE AS YOU MAKE CHANGES THEY
NEED TO BE STAGED- WE'VE TALKED
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS. ABOUT THE
NEED. EIGHT USUALLY BEST- DON'T
FOR DOES NOT HAVE DAY. CAN NO
DOES NEEDS TO BE FIRST SECOND
AND THIRD. OBVIOUSLY IT'S- IF
YOU GOING CHANGE THE PROCESS. OF
THAT BEFORE YOU IMPLEMENT THAT
PROCESS YOU'VE PROVIDED
INFORMATION AND- TRAINING TO IT
TO PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO BE
INVOLVED IN THAT PROCESS OF
TRYING TO ACCESS THAT PROCESS.
SO CLEARLY SOME THINGS LIKE THAT
BASIC INFORMATION AND TRAINING
NEEDS TO HAPPEN FIRST BEFORE WE-
FULLY INTO THAT THAT PROCESS. AS
WE MAKE THAT CHANGE OF COURSE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S DONE
CORRECTLY- WE'VE PUT IN OUR
LANGUAGE FEEDBACK LOOPS- BUT
WITH WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON A
RECURRING ADVISORY GROUP
INVOLVING THE HEARING OFFICE.
OUR HEARINGS ARE OF THE ACTUAL
FORMAL HEARINGS ARE RUN. OF FOR
US- UNDER CONTRACT WITH
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS. AND THEY WOULD PARTNER
WITH US AS WELL- IN. ALL OF THE
EFFORTS WE'VE DESCRIBED IN OUR
PROPOSAL- TO GET RECURRING
FEEDBACK ABOUT HOW THINGS ARE
GOING. ON A CAP OVER EMPHASIZE
THE ABILITY NOT JUST TO LISTEN
TO PEOPLE BUT TO HEAR WHAT
THEY'RE SAYING. ON BROUGH AT- SO
AT. AND AS THE DIRECTOR
MENTIONED WE HAVE COMMITMENTS
FROM DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES FROM THE DIRECTOR ON
DOWN TO THEIR TEAM. SIX SPEND
THAT PARTNERSHIP AND- WE'VE
PROVIDED SOME RESOURCES TO
DEDICATE TO THIS CHANGE AS WELL-
SO YOU KNOW W'RE REALLY EXCITED
TO BE ABLE TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
PARTICULARLY WHEN PEOPLE ARE
UNABLE TO RESOLVE THEIR ISSUES
AT LOWER LEVELS TO MAKE THE
PROCESS ACCESSIBLE IF YOU WELL
IN THE BROADEST POSSIBLE SENSE.
EXCUSE ME. THE NEXT QUESTION ON
THE AGENDA ASK US ABOUT A
DIFFERENT TOPIC OR WHETHER THERE
WERE ANY LESSONS LEARNED WITH
THE SELF DETERMINATION
OMBUDSPERSON OFFICE THAT CAN BE
LEVERAGED WHEN DESIGN DOES
DESIGNING THE SYSTEM WIDE ALMOST
FIRST IN OFFICE- AND THE SHORT
ANSWER IS YES ABSOLUTELY WE'VE
BOTH AFFIRMS LESSONS AND LEARNED
LESSONS WELL A COUPLE THAT WE
USE- IT- A COUPLE THAT WE HAVE A
FIRM. WELL WE FOUND IT REALLY
HELPFUL AND WE'VE GOTTEN A
CERTAINLY EVEN YEARS SO THIS IS
JUST HAVING MULTIPLE WAYS FOR
PEOPLE TO REACH THE OFFICE YOU
KNOW PHONE CALL EMAIL ADDRESS
AND ALSO ON THE INTERNET THERE'S
A WET INTAKE FORM WHERE PEOPLE
COULD SUBMIT ONLINE. QUEST FOR
HELP KIND OF MAKE NOT FROM IT'S
- FOR PEOPLE- OPENING THE
OFFICES AS- WHILE HIRING-
PERMANENT STAFF SUNDAY THAT'S A
US. ON AND GROW THANKS TO KATIE
HOW. ARE AT ON FIRST FORGET THIS
AND HELPING WITHOUT HIRING THE
SOONER WE BEEN ABLE TO OPEN
THEIR ALSO STIRRED HIS CENTER
PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS
THAT ASSISTANCE- LESSON LEARNED
RELATED TO HIRING START SOONER-
SO WE'RE WE'RE ON THAT. WE ARE
WORKING ON PAPERWORK- AND IS FOR
THE HIRING PROCESS AND WE WANT
TO BE READY- JET JANET THE
GROUND RUNNING ON THE
PRESUMPTION THIS PROPOSAL. WOULD
GET APPROVED OR NOT TO BE
PRESUMPTIVE OF THAT BUT TO BE
READY FOR THAT- THE OTHER THING
THAT WE HAD A FRIEND IS- THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING REALLY. IS
HOW MUCH HOW MUCH PEOPLE REALLY
NEED A PLACE TO GO TELL THEIR
STORY AND TO GET UNBIASED ADVICE
AND ASSISTANCE. THAT'S REALLY
REALLY CRITICAL. LESSONS LEARNED
KIND OF INVASION OF HAVING STAFF
UP AND READY TO GO- AND TO HELP
PEOPLE- WE NEED WAYS TO TRACK
WITH THEIR TIMELINESS REMEMBER
WHO'S CALLED WHEN THERE'S CALLED
WHAT FOLLOW UP WE'VE COMMITTED
TO. AND HOW THAT ISSUE WAS
RESOLVED. NOT BECAUSE FIRST WERE
IN PART T THATPERSON
SPECIFICALLY BUT ON THE THIRD
IT'S IMPORTANT TO THEM BUT ALSO
TO US IN OUR ABILITY TO
IDENTIFY. SYSTEMIC ISSUES IN THE
SYSTEM. SO MISTER SWISS CABLE
YOU HAVE FROM AND LATER ON A
DIFFERENT PROPOSAL BOB AND HIS
TEAM IN THE I. T. DIVISION IS
WORKING ON A SOLUTION FOR US- SO
THAT WE- HAVE A MORE FORMAL WAY
OF DOING THAT. SO I BOTH LESSONS
LEARNED AND LESSONS UP FROM
THERE. WELL I BELIEVE THAT
ANSWERS THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
LISTED IN THE AGENDA OF COURSE
HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AND
APPRECIATE THEIR COMMITTEE HONOR
IN THIS PROPOSAL AS A SENSIBLE
IMPORTANT PART OF OUR
DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY TO FOCUS ON
OUTCOMES FOR THE PEOPLE. THAT WE
SERVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
WE DO APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU'VE
DONE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. HEY
CHRIS FOR OATMEAL DEPARTMENT
FINANCE NOTHING FURTHER OUT ON
THIS ITEM THANK YOU OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH LMAO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR SONYA
PADDOCK WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE HAVE
REVIEWED THE PROPOSAL AND THE
ASSOCIATED TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE. AND THINK THE PROPOSAL
IDENTIFIES AND TRIES TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE KEY PROBLEMS THAT
HAVE RAISED- IN THE- EARNINGS
AND DISPUTE RESOLUTION PROCESS.
IMMEDIATELY WE DO NOT HAVE MAJOR
CONCERNS WITH THE PROPOSAL
HOWEVER WE ARE CONTINUING TO
REVIEW THE DETAILS AND WILL
REACH OUT TO SUB COMMITTEE STAFF
IF. WE HAVE ANY SUGGESTIONS OVER
THE NEXT COUPLE OF MONTHS AS WE
CLOSE OUT THE BUDGET. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- LET'S MOVE
NOW TO SOME STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE
WERE INVITED FOR THIS AND LET'S
BEGIN WITH THE MISS VIVIAN ONE
WITH A DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU SENATOR
EGGMAN MY COLLEAGUES AND I ARE
HERE TODAY NOT ONLY AS DRC
ATTORNEY ASSEMBLING OF PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
WE'RE GRATEFUL TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THEM AND THE THOUSANDS
OF OTHER RESEARCH IDENTITY
SYSTEM. WE THANK THE DEPARTMENT
FOR A KNOWLEDGE IN THAT THE
CURRENT HEARING PROCESS CAN BE
INTIMIDATING AND EXPERIENCED AS
UNFAIR PARTICULARLY BY THOSE FOR
WHOM ENGLISH IS NOT A FIRST
LANGUAGE OR FOR WHOM QUESTIONING
AUTHORITY. CULTURALLY DIFFICULT.
AND WE APPLAUD THE DEPARTMENT
FOR MAKING A PUBLIC COMMITMENT
DURING THIS MATTER. DO THAT
TOGETHER. IT STARTS BY GIVING
DISABLED PEOPLE A SAFE WAY TO
SPEAK UP WITH THE BEANS BETWEEN
WHEN THEY FEEL LIKE THEY'RE NOT
GETTING THEM. THAT CHANGE NEEDS
TO HAPPEN BOTH FROM THE BOTTOM
UP AND TOP DOWN. MY COLLEAGUE
WE'LL TALK LATER ABOUT TOP AND-
BUT I'LL START BY TALKING ABOUT
CHANGE IN THE BOTTOM. WHICH
MEANS ELEVATE THE VOICES OF
DISABLED PEOPLE AND DESIGNING
AROUND HERE EXPERIENCES AND
NEEDS. FIRST WE RECOMMEND
ESTABLISHING SOMETHING THAT DOES
NOT CURRENTLY EXIST IN THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WHICH IS A
COMMITTEE FOR THE SPECIFIC
PURPOSE OF ADVISING THE HEARING
OFFICE ON HOW TO IMPROVE HEARING
PROCEDURES. OTHER HEARING
SYSTEMS HAVE LONG HAD THIS KIND
OF ADVISORY COMMITTEE. THE
OFFICE OF ADMINISTRATIVE
HEARINGS ALREADY DOES THIS FOR
ITS SPECIAL EDUCATION YOU
PROCESS HEARING. ANY DEVICE
RICAN'S BOTH SIDES MEET WITH THE
HEARING OFFICE TO DISCUSS EVERY
DAY IN THE WEEDS PROBLEMS LIKE
SCHEDULING AND CALENDARING WHERE
AND HOW TO SUBMIT CERTAIN
DOCUMENTS REQUEST. TECHNOLOGY
MEETING LOGISTICS FOR SOMEONE
WITH ADD ASSEMBLY MEMBER. FIGURE
OUT THE DETAILS CAN BE A BEAR TO
ACCESSING FAIR HEARING. NOT JUST
THE DEPARTMENT MAKES GOOD POLICY
SENSE. THAT'S RIGHT VIæT
COMMITTEES LIKE THIS HAVE BEEN
STANDARD PRACTICE AND OTHER
DISABILITY BENEFITS SYSTEMS FOR
SOME TIME AND IT'S TIME TO DO
THIS FOR HEARINGS IN THE D.
SYSTEM AS WELL. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT SUGGESTIONS FOR
IMPROVING HEARING OFFICER
TRAINING ARE A GOOD START STILL
MISSING ONE CRITICAL PIECE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR HEARING OFFICERS
TO HEAR DIRECTLY FROM THE VERY
PEOPLE THAT THE DECISIONS IMPACT
. D. R. C. TOLD US ABOUT HEARING
OFFICERS YOU SEEN IMPATIENT WITH
THE PERCENT INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY WHO TALKED OVER THEM.
STILL I'M FAMILIAR WITH HOW TO
INTERACT WITH THEM ON A BASIC
LEVEL. PEOPLE WITH IT DESERVE
BETTER. WANT TO REGAIN TRUST IN
THIS HEARING SYSTEM ONLY TO KNOW
THE HEARING ARE HEARING THEM.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT FOR
HEARING OFFICER TRYING TO HAVE A
COMPONENT THAT GIVES PEOPLE WITH
IT. DOES REPRESENT THEM AN
OPPORTUNITY EVEN IF IT'S JUST
ONCE A YEAR SHARE THEIR
EXPERIENCES DIRECTLY WITH
HEARING. SO THEY CAN LOOK AT THE
HEARING ON HAVE AT LEAST SOME
BACKGROUND SOME CONTEXT ABOUT
WHO THEY ARE AND WHAT THEIR
ISSUES IN THEIR LIVES I LIVE. AS
DEFINED BY THEM. CREATING A FAIR
SHARING SYSTEM STARTS WITH
LISTENING TO THE PEOPLE IT
SERVES. BUT IT DOESN'T END THERE
. IT REQUIRES STRUCTURAL CHANGES
IN AND THAT'S WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
WAS SPEAKING. THANKS AGAIN FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION NOW
WE'LL MOVE ON TO YOUR COLLEAGUE
MISTER WILL WIENER- FROM ALSO
FROM DRC. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR IN THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT PROPOSAL. I ALSO WANT
TO THANK JDS AND DIRECTOR
PARCHMENT FOR GETTING THESE LONG
OVER TO THEIR HEARING OR FORMS
ON THE TABLE. MY COLLEAGUES JUST
HIGHLIGHTED THE IMPORTANCE OF
CREATING AN EQUITABLE HEARING
SYSTEM FROM THE BOTTOM UP. I'M
GOING TO TALK ABOUT HOW WE CAN
DO THIS FROM THE TOP DOWN BY
CHANGING THE STRUCTURE OF THE
HEARING PROCESS ITSELF. OKAY
SMART. WITTY INSTEAD OF A
QUALITY. BECAUSE HERE'S THE
THING ABOUT THE CURRENT AWAY H.
HEARING PROCESS. DESPITE THE
ENORMOUS POWER IMBALANCE BETWEEN
REGIONAL CENTERS AND THE PEOPLE
SERVED BY THEM. IT TREATS BOTH
SIDES THE SAME. IF YOU EXAMPLES
WHEN HEARING IS FILE NEITHER THE
PERSON SERVED OR REGIONAL CENTER
HAVE A RIGHT TO COUNSEL.
ALTHOUGH WE KNOW WHICH I CAN
AFFORD ONE. BOTH THE PERSON
SERVED AND THE REGIONAL CENTER
NEED TO EXCHANGE WITNESSED TESTS
AND DOCUMENTARY EVIDENCE BEFORE
THE HEARING. ALTHOUGH THERE'S
ONLY ONE SIDE WITH FULL TIME
STAFF TO HELP PREPARE THESE
MATERIALS. HEARING OFFICER RULED
SPECS BOTH SIDES TO PRESENT
THEIR CASE TO THE BEST OF THEIR
ABILITY. ALTHOUGH WE KNOW WHICH
SIDE PRACTICE. AND BOTH THE
PERSON SERVED IN THE REGIONAL
CENTER CONFINEMENT PEEL IN
SUPERIOR COURT TO TEN NEWS
ALTHOUGH WE KNOW WHICH SIDE HAS
THE RESOURCES TO DO THIS. IT'S
NO SURPRISE THEN THAT 70% OF ALL
CASES WITHDRAWN BEFORE THEY EVER
GET TO HEARING. WHY PEOPLE ARE
OVERWHELMED AT THE PROCESS AND
JUST GIVING OUT. ANY CASES THAT
GO HEARING HIM FOR WINNING ABOUT
12% OF THE TIME. IT'S THESE
TYPES OF INEQUITABLE OUTCOMES
THAT UNDERMINE THE TRUST PEOPLE
HAVE IN OUR SYSTEMS AND
UNDERSCORES THE NEED TO CREATE A
HEARING PROCESS THAT LEVELS THE
PLAYING FIELD. THE DEPARTMENT'S
PROPOSAL IS A VERY STRONG STEP
IN THIS DIRECTION. HOW PROHIBITS
REGIONAL CENTERS FROM HIRING
ATTORNEYS TO GO UP AGAINST
DISABLED PEOPLE AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND THAT'S THE PERSON
SERVED ALSO HAS AN ATTORNEY. IT
ALSO GIVES PEOPLE THE OPTION TO
ACCESS MEDIATION WITHOUT HAVING
TO GRAPPLE WITH WHETHER TO ASK
FOR A HEARING AT THE SAME TIME.
TAKEN TOGETHER THESE TWO CHANGES
REMOVED CONSIDERABLE DRIVERS OF
THE POWER IMBALANCE THAT EXISTS
BETWEEN PEOPLE IN REGIONAL
CENTRES. BUT THERE'S STILL MORE
TO BE DONE AND WE CAN LOOK TO
THE HEARING PROCESS FOR OTHER
PUBLIC ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS FOR
GUIDANCE. LAKE TSS STATE
HEARINGS GREATER EQUITY IS
INTERWOVEN INTO THAT PROCESS.
YOU'RE JUST A FEW EXAMPLES.
BEFORE THE HEARING THE AGENCY
THAT MADE THE DECISION GIVES THE
PERSON A POSITION STATEMENT WITH
ITS ARGUMENTS AND EVIDENCE. THE
PERSON DOESN'T HAVE TO GIVE THE
AGENCY ANYTHING UNTIL THE
HEARING. DURING THE HEARING
HEARING OFFICERS HELP
UNREPRESENTED PEOPLE CAN ON
THEIR CASE INSTEAD OF EXPECTING
THE PERSON TO AUTOMATICALLY KNOW
WHAT TO SAY OR DO. WE CALL THIS
ENGAGED NEUTRALITY. WE ALSO KNOW
THE HEARING OFFICERS CAN GET IT
WRONG. SO AFTER THE HEARING
PEOPLE CAN RECOVER ATTORNEYS
FEES IF THEY APPEAL THEIR CASE
TO THE SUPERIOR COURT AND WHEN.
THESE THESE CRITICAL FEATURES
EITHER DON'T EXIST OR ONLY
PARTIALLY EXISTENCE APARTMENTS
PROPOSED REFORMS. MORE CAN BE
DONE. I'LL CLOSE MY TESTIMONY
WITH THIS. PEOPLE AND THEIR
FAMILIES TO SERVICE SAFE PROCESS
FOR RESOLVING CONFLICTS WITH
REGIONAL CENTERS. ONE WHERE THE
BALANCE OF POWERS LAST YEAR.
WHERE PEOPLE HAVE A MEANINGFUL
VOICE IN THE DECISIONS THAT
AFFECT THEIR LIVES WHERE THE
SYSTEM BILLS OPEN AND HELPFUL
THE PEOPLE WHO REPRESENT
THEMSELVES. WE WERE PEOPLE FEEL
TREATED WITH DIGNITY AND RESPECT
. THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PROPOSAL
A GOOD STEP IN THE RIGHT TREE IN
THE DISTRACTION. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
DEPARTMENT IN THE SUB COMMITTEE
TO GET IT RIGHT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY TODAY BUT DIRECTOR
BRIDGMAN OR MR AS YOU BRING
COULD YOU WANT TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT- FIRST JUST THE BOTTOM
UP KIND OF ENGAGEMENT ON THAT
THE PROCESS IS IN PLANS TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE THE CLIENTS AND THE
CLIENTS FAMILIES VOICE CENTRAL
TO THE PROCESS. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- SO FIRST WE DO HAVE
WITHIN THE PROPOSAL I'M AN
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT IS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH- DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES. ON THAT WOULD
BE INCLUSIVE AND PURPOSEFUL FOR
SELF ADVOCATES FAMILY MEMBERS-
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH OUR STAKEHOLDERS AS TO YOU
KNOW HOW WE- LOOK AT AND
CONSTRUCT THAT ADVISORY GROUP
AND- WELCOME AND BUT- AND
RECOMMENDATIONS- AND THEN.
MISTER TRIPPY SERVING AND MAY
HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL COMMENTS AS
WELL. IF YOU DRINK OF. SURE
THANKS THANKS AGAIN- YEAH I
THINK THAT THAT POINT IS EXACTLY
RIGHT WE WANT TO INCLUDE THE
VOICES OF PEOPLE THAT WE'RE
SERVING AND WE'RE EXPERIENCE IN
THE PROCESS OF THOSE WE SERVE.
THEIR FAMILIES AND SUPPORT
NETWORKS IN THE PROCESS- SHARE
THIS MISS MISS LINERS- RETIRED
TEST AND KIND OF THE CHANGE ARE
REALLY GOOD STAR WE'RE WE'RE
OPEN TO TALK ABOUT WHAT I YOU
STILL- WE DO HAVE- PROVISIONS
AROUND THE APPEARANCE OF COUNSEL
AT THE HEARINGS AS HE NOTED. ON
PAGE TWELVE OF OUR PROPOSAL- WE
HAVE DETAILS ABOUT THE TRAINING
THAT ARE- THE MINISTRY OF WINE
JUDGES WILL GO THROUGH THAT'S ON
PAGE TWENTY TWO AND TWENTY
THREE. ENGAGED NEUTRALITY ON THE
CONDUCT OF THE HEARING OVER ALL
AGES TWENTY FOUR AND TWENTY
FIVE- IMPLEMENTATION OF
DECISIONS MAKING SURE THAT THAT
STUFF HAPPENS ON PAGE THIRTY. WE
HAVE THE DIRECTOR'S ABILITY TO
LOOK AT A PROPOSED DECISIONS AND
THEN YOU KNOW IMPORTANTLY BACK
YOU KNOW CLOSING WITH THAT THE
VOICE OF THE CONSUMER. THE
FAMILY WE DO HAVE A PROPOSAL FOR
A STAKEHOLDER ADVISORY GROUP-
IT'S ON PAGE THIRTY TWO OF THE
LANGUAGE THAT'S NOT THE KIND OF
THE STAFF COMMON AND- MISTER
LINERS. COMMON AS WELL. AROUND
THAT AND IT'S A VERY. GROUP IN A
APARTMENT BUT ALSO THE HEARING.
AND FRANKLY YOU KNOW WITNESSES
AND WHERE DGI WAS UP WITH US
THEY ARE POINT US TO THE
LANGUAGE USED FOR. EDUCATION AND
THE HEARINGS THAT THEY CONDUCTED
HE USES A MODEL FOR THIS
LANGUAGE AND YOU KNOW.
EVERYTHING ELSE ABOUT TRYING TO
TELL YOU IT'S PERFECT. WE'RE
OPEN FEEDBACK ON IT BUT ONE OF
THE TO BE AWARE THAT ALL OF
THOSE THINGS ARE PART OF OUR-
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOU'RE A REAL. USE USE
PREVIOUS MOM THAT WAS VERY
HELPFUL FOR YOU- IN ADDITION TO
REALLY TRYING TO EMBED THIS.
THROUGHOUT THE VOICE. OF THE-
THE PARTICIPANT- OKAY SO. SO I
THINK WE ALL HEARD COMMITMENTS
TO KEEP ON WORKING ON THIS AND
CONTINUE TO INTEGRATE- VOICES OF
CONSTITUENTS- AND PARTICIPANTS
AND- AND I THINK WE'RE ALL GONNA
BE DIVING DEEPER INTO ALL THE
DETAILS. TO MAKE URE WE GET IT
RIGHT. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WITH THAT I THINK WILL MOVE
ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO- AND I
UNDERSTAND- DIPPY DIRECTOR CARLA
CUSTOM YOU KNOW WILL BE
PRESENTING FOR THIS. DISCUSS ANY
OTHER YEAR IN OF SO WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR PROBABLY
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. FOR THIS
SIX ISSUE THE RESEARCHING ONCE
REQUEST. WE'RE REQUESTING TO AND
A HALF MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
BUDGET YEAR TO BEGIN HIRING
NINETEEN POSITIONS- THIS WILL BE
THREE POINT THREE MILLION ON.
YES THEY'RE FULLY FULLY HIGHER.
THIS WILL HELP THE DEPARTMENT TO
IMPROVE OUR TECH AS- SUPPORT AND
ADDITIONAL RESEARCH STUFF. GIVEN
SOME OF THE INCREASING PROGRAM
INITIATIVES AND HELPING TO
IMPROVE THE PERSON CENTERED
OUTCOMES AND EQUITABLE ACCESS TO
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES. SO-
SUPPORTING BOTH ARE. YOU NINETY
AS WELL AS OUR RESEARCH CHANGED.
WITHOUT ALTERING OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE TO ADDRESS THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GREAT THANK THANKS A LOT OF THE
RELATIVELY BRIEF ON THIS ONE
JUST OBSERVER IN THIS IS ANOTHER
CRITICAL COMPONENT FOR OUR
DELIVER ON HEALTH CONSTRUCTING
THE VOLUME OF INFORMATION DATA
THAT WE WANT TO TURN THE
INFORMATION IS GOING TO BE
DRAMATICALLY EXPANDED THROUGH
THE- INITIATIVE SUPPORT FUND IN
THE BUDGET ACT LAST YEAR. IN OUR
ON GOING OUT FOR SOME. ONE
QUESTION WAS ASKED ABOUT THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
SPECIFICALLY THAT PIECE OF THAT-
ABOUT THE SUBMISSION OF DATA
REPORTS REGARDING CHILDREN
SURVIVALIST OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES SYSTEM. AND THE CHILD
WELFARE SYSTEM- ANY IN THIS- WE
YEARS FORMER FOR. HERE IT IS
ASSEMBLY CHANGED TO DELETE THE
ANNUAL REPORTING WORK- AND WELL
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A NEGATIVE WHAT
WE'RE PROPOSING INSTEAD IS TO
WEB POSTERS FOR GREATER
TRANSPARENCY AND DO IT MORE
FREQUENTLY- IN MY- DECADE OF
EXPERIENCE A LITTLE LONGER THAN
A DECADE OF EXPERIENCE WITH THIS
PARTICULAR REPORT IT'S NOT ONE
THAT WE GOT QUESTIONS ABOUT. AND
WE THINK IN PART BECAUSE IT'S
NOT STRUCTURED IN A WAY THAT
MAKES THE INFORMATION USABLE FOR
PEOPLE SO WE WOULD LIKE TO PUT
THIS INFORMATION INSTEAD ON THE
WEBSITE UPDATED MORE FREQUENTLY.
CONTINUED PARTNERSHIP WITH
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES.
THERE WAS A COMMENT MADE IN A
COUPLE RECENT CONVERSATIONS KIND
OF WE WANT TO KEEP THIS
INFORMATION ALL IN ONE PLACE.
OUR SUGGEST WONDERFUL CAN HAVE A
WAY. LINK TO THE OTHER
DEPARTMENT WRESTLE SOUND WELL WE
INTEND TO DO THAT- AND THAT'S
REALLY THE POINT- IS TO MAKE
THIS I'M MORE INTO- LOT MORE
INTERACTIVE FOR PEOPLE MORE
TRANSPARENT FOR PEOPLE. HE'S A
MORATORIUM RESTORED ATTENDS ONE
POLICY MAKING ALL NOTE ABOUT TEN
DAYS AGO WE GOT FEEDBACK FROM A
NUMBER OF ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS
NOT OPPOSING DELETE. FOR SELFISH. OTHER SPECIFIC DATA TO ADDED-
TOMORROW AT EIGHT THIRTY. THE TO
DO SOCIAL SIR ON OUR TO OUR OUR
A CONVERSATION ABOUT. WHAT'S
WHAT'S FEASIBLE AND DO A AND
AFTER WE TO HAVE A ANSWER
RELATIVELY FOR THE IN A PER.
THEIR THEIR STOCK LOOK AT. THE
INTO OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
WORK. AND WHAT WHATEVER BE
USEFUL FOR FOLKS OF MORE TO COME
OUT ONCE- AND APPRECIATE THAT
THE- SINCE. OF THE STRIKE AS
WELL. THANK VERY MUCH- PARTNER
FINANCE. CHRIS O'NEILL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
FURTHER AT ON THIS ITEM MANAGER
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISSPENT.
WITH THE L. A. L. AND SINCE
YOU'RE IN THE FOR CHANGE TO THE
REPORT THAT MR CERVENKA WAS JUST
DISCUSSING- WE WOULD NOTE THAT-
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY REPORTING
ABOUT A PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE
GROUPS OF CHILDREN IS IMPORTANT
BUT BUT WE AGREE THAT THAT THE
INFORMATION ALSO NEEDS TO BE
USEFUL AND- I HATED IT. AWAY AT
- IT'S- RIGHT PEOPLE AT THE
RIGHT TIME. I'M WE THINK THE
HAVING. THE PURPOSE OF SERVICES
AND VIDEO JOIN WE POSE IN FOR ON
THE FOR PUBLIC AND LEGISLATIVE
REVIEW MIGHT MAKE SENSE AND IS A
MORE TRANSPARENT HERE. TEN A
MORE TRANSPARENT WAY OF
PROVIDING THE DATA HOWEVER- THE
LEGISLATURE ME STILL MAY NEED TO
UNDERSTAND SORT OF WHAT'S
IMPORTANT ABOUT THAT
INFORMATION. SO ONE POSSIBLE ON
A COMPROMISE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER.
WE SEEM TO HAVE LOST YOU
HISPANIC. OKAY I'M SURE IT'S
APPROPRIATE I WOULD JUST NOTE
THAT OF COURSE AS ANY PROPOSALS
WERE HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN COMMENTS
AND FEEDBACK ON THIS AND SO AT
AT SUCH TIME AS WE RECEIVE THAT
WE'RE HAPPY TO RESPOND. OKAY SO
PERHAPS TO MOVE UP AND CIRCLE
BACK TO SEE IF OF MISS PEDICABS
ANYTHING ELSE BUT YEAH THAT'S
WHAT I WAS GOING TO SAY SO IT'S
NOT LIKE. YOU THOUGHT OR JUST.
DROPPED TO THE DIFFERENT WAY
THAT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'VE BEEN
GETTING A LOT OF FEEDBACK THAT
MAYBE WE SHOULD- ON THE OPEN TO
CHANGE. AND REPORT. JEFF WANT TO
SEE THAT IN AND WANT TO KNOW-
THE WAY TO BE ABLE TO DISPLAY IT
BOTH FOR TRANSPARENCY AND- AND
VALUE AND USABILITY IS THAT WHAT
WAS THAT WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
EVERYBODY THAT WE'RE NOT QUITE
DONE WAS PROPOSAL YET GOING TO
COME BACK WITH SOME MORE DETAILS
FLESHED OUT. YES IN THE
INTERPRETATION OKAY OKAY AND
THEN EVERYTHING ELSE SOUNDS LIKE
HERE YOU REALLY ARE TRYING TO
MOVE THE AGENCY UP. UP UP CLOSER
TO WHERE WE ARE IN IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THAN WHERE WE WERE
PERHAPS A DECADE AGO. AND I WILL
NOTE THAT SINCE WE'VE BEEN
HOLDING HEARINGS HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO GET OUT AND VISIT SOME
CENTERS BOTH- THE CENTERS AND
SOME HOT. BIRD YOUR- PARTICIPANT
RESIDING IN- CERTAINLY ENJOYED
MY TIME THERE AND HEARING FROM
THE FOLKS WHO ARE OUT IN THE
FIELD. DOING THE ACTUAL WORK AS
WELL AS- SOME OF YOUR
PARTICIPANTS WHO WE GOT TO. TALK
AND VISIT WITH AS WELL. OKAY SO
I'M HOPING HISPANIC OR SOMEBODY
IS GOING TO HELP HER GET COME
BACK TO US- BUT IT AND WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THAN ISSUE NUMBER
FOUR- CLINICAL FACILITY CLINICAL
SOFTWARE REPLACEMENT AND LIKE
TRONIC HEALTH RECORD
IMPLEMENTATION- AND THAT IS
WITH- STILL WITH DIRECTOR
PARCHMENT AND WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE WITH YOU DIRECTOR. THIS IS
CARLA BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY
JUST WANT TO DOUBLE CHECK IF
YOU. WANTED TO ROOT NUMBER.
THREE I READ THREE BUT I SAID
FOR SEE HOW IT WORKS LIKE THAT
WITH THAT WITHIN AGING BRAIN
OKAY YES THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING
WITH DIRECTOR BARGE MEANT THAT I
THINK I CHIEF- J. COULD. THANK
YOU SPEAKING FOR DRUG
ABRIDGEMENT- PUBLIC A FEW OTHER
WITH THE DEPARTMENT MOBILE
SERVICES THE ISSUE THREE IS
REQUESTING RESOURCES FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX THOUSAND AND
POSITION OF AUTHORITY FOR FOUR
FOUR POSITIONS ONE NEW AND THREE
THAT HAVE BEEN REDIRECTED US FOR
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF THESE
POSITIONS AND DOLLARS WITH
SUPPORT- ACCOUNTING WORK AS WELL
AS INFORMATION- COMPLYING WITH
THE STATE MANDATE FOR ELECTRONIC
FORMATS. OF STANDARDIZED
INFORMATION. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OKAY MR NOW. OKAY
CHRIS ROAD NEAR THE PERMANENT
FINANCE NOTHING FURTHER OUT ON
THE SIDELINE CARE THANK YOU OKAY
THIS PEDIGREE BACK. AND I AM SO
SORRY MADAM CHAIR OUR INTERNET
JUST WENT DOWN FOR A MINUTE SO.
MY APOLOGIES OKAY WE TRIED WE
MUSTERED ON WITHOUT YOU. YEAH I
WAS HOPING. OKAY AND NOW WE'RE
ON ISSUE NUMBER THREE-
THANKS TO HAVE YOU FOR A MINUTE. OKAY.
WELL. I DIDN'T HAVE ANY ISSUES
WITH THIS ONE- I DON'T THINK IT
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER FOR
THEM. AND THEN TO WORK AND WHAT
WILL WHAT. UP THE INTERNET-
BEGINS TO WORK. OKAY MOVING NOT
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- JUMPS WITH CABLE
DEPARTMENT DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES- THIS ISSUE NUMBER FOR
THE FACILITY CLINICAL SOFTWARE
PLACEMENT ELECTRONIC HEALTH
RECORD IMPLEMENTATION OF
DEPARTMENT OF DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES I REQUEST ONE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS IN FISCAL
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY
THREE AND TWO POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND THEN TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE AND I'M GOING
TO PLAN FOR THE REPLACEMENT OF
CLINICAL SOFTWARE USED AT THE
STATE OPERATORS RESIDENTIAL
FACILITIES. THE REQUEST INCLUDES
TERM TO PERMANENT POSITIONS- TWO
YEAR LIMITED TERM RESOURCES
EQUIVALENT TO THREE POSITIONS.
SALTING SERVICE FOR TWO YEARS.
THE PERMANENT POSITIONS WITH THE
FINAL TRACK THE LEGAL REGULATORY
LICENSING AND CERTIFICATION
REQUIREMENTS TO SUPPORT CLINICAL
FUNCTIONALITY. REPORTING AND
COMPLIANCE EFFORTS IN ADDITION
TO THE POSITION RESOURCES EDS
ALSO REQUEST FUNDS TO ACQUIRE
CONSULTING SERVICES. NECESSARY
TO COMPLETE THE PROJECT PLANNING
AND PREPARATION ACTIVITIES FOR
THE FUTURE CLINICAL FACILITIES
OFFER REPLACEMENT PROJECT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DEPARTMENT FINANCE
THROUGH NOW. THIS FOR OATMEAL
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NOTHING
FURTHER OUT ON THIS ITEM I'M
SURE THANK YOU OKAY MISDIRECTED
YOU MAKE IT BACK AGAIN. I DID I
I'VE- LEARNED FROM MY PHONE- OUR
WORK CONNECTION KEEPS CUTTING
OUT MANY APOLOGIES FOR THAT- ARE
YOU STILL ON ISSUE THREE. FROM
WHICH WE MOVED ON THE ISSUE FOR
BUT THE ONES DID YOU HAVE
ANYTHING BOND THREE I DIDN'T
HAVE. A LOT OF ISSUES ON THREE.
SO NO WE ACTUALLY DID NOT HAVE
COMMENTS ON THREE OR FOUR OKAY
OKAY. OKAY THANK YOU WELL DON'T
DON'T TALK ANYMORE THAT'S IT FOR
NOW AND THAT WILL SAVE IT- THE
ONLY THING THAT I THAT I WOULD
SAY IS JUST AND TO TAKE DOCTOR
PANTS PLACES NINE HERE. ANYTIME
WE DO ANY KIND OF I. T. JUST
MAKE SURE MAKE SURE MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE TRACKING THAT
PROJECT THAT WE HAVE THE
OUTCOMES THAT WE WANT TO KNOW
WHAT WE WANT TO MEASURE- AND
THAT YOU KNOW ANYTIME WE'RE
CHANGING A SYSTEM FROM ONE TO
ANOTHER AFTER THIRTY YEARS. AND
THERE'S GONNA BE SOME BLIPS AND
SO LET'S PLEASE PLAN THOSE
CONTINGENCIES AND MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE A GOOD RELATIONSHIP.
ABOVE THE BENDERS AND THE- AND
THE CONSULTANTS SO THAT WE CAN.
KEEP OUR HANDS ON WHAT'S GOING
ON. CERTAINLY THANK YOU MEDICAL
CARE. VERY MUCH OKAY. FROM ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE. NOW. I'M HOPING
YOU'RE GOING TO STAY HERE WITH
US THROUGHOUT THIS ONE MISTAKE
YES YES I I'M I'M ON MY STABLE
PHONE. HAVING BETTER LUCK WITH
THAT THE MY COMPUTER SO-
APOLOGIES AGAIN FOR THE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES I'M ISSUE
FIVE CONCERNS SENATE BUDGET
PRIORITIES IMPROVING SERVICES
FOR THE INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
COMMUNITY. THE SUB COMMITTEE HAS
ASKED OUR OFFICE THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE TO PRESENT THE
FOLLOWING PROPOSALS AND WE WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THIS DOES NOT
CONSTITUTE. AN L. A-
RECOMMENDATION PER SE BUT WERE
READING THESE ON BEHALF OF THE
SUB COMMITTEE- THE SENATE BUDGET
PRIORITIES THE SENATE IS
CONSIDERING THE FOLLOWING
PROPOSALS TO IMPROVE SERVICES TO
THE INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES IDG
COMMUNITY. ONE X. CELERY BERMAN
SHIN OF THE RATE STUDY APPROVED
IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
ACT BY ONE YEAR TO ADDRESS
STAFFING SHORTAGES AND SERVICE
DISRUPTIONS. INTO REQUIRING
REGULAR UPDATES TO THE RATE
MODELS IN THE GDS RATE STUDY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I BELIEVE WE ARE%
GOING TO HAVE SOME STAKEHOLDER
INPUT ON THAT- AND THAT WILL BE
JORDAN LINDSEY THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ARC IN UCP
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR A GREAT AGENDA- MY
NAME IS JORDAN LINDSAY I'M
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ARC
UNITED STRUGGLE POLICY
CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION. I
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY ON BEHALF OF
THE TWENTY TWO OUR CHAPTERS IN
TEN U. C. P. AFFILIATES ACROSS
THE STATE. NUMBER THIRTY SEVEN
BOARD MEMBERS COMPRISED OF
PARENTS AND FAMILY MEMBERS
INDIVIDUALS WITH ID. WELL AS
INDIVIDUALS WITH ID TEAM I ALSO
SPEAK TO ON BEHALF OF THE LATER
COALITION. AND THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF CRITICAL ISSUES FACING
CALIFORNIA'S INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY
COMMUNITY A FEW WHICH HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DISCUSSED TODAY.
BUT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED THE TOP
PRIORITY. AS A CRITICAL
WORKFORCE SHORTAGE THROUGHOUT
THE SYSTEM. CAUSING INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES TO GO WITHOUT
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES. AS WE
KNOW IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE DDS RATE STUDY IDENTIFIED
THAT DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES WERE
BEING UNDERPAID ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION. LAST YEAR THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDING OF COURSE
THIS COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH LEANED INTO OUR COMMUNITY
AND THREW A ROCK EFFORTS. CLUE
OF COURSE YOU SENATE LEADER. AND
ASSEMBLY IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ADVOCACY
COMMUNITY WAS ABLE TO PASS THE
FULL IMPLEMENTATION OF THE RATE
STUDY STARTING WITH 25% IN JUST
THIS PAST APRIL. THE
IMPLEMENTATION WILL INCLUDE
EFFORTS TO CREATE A TRULY PERSON
SUPPORTS AND SERVICES AND THERE
IS REAL HOPE AND OPTIMISM
OPTIMISM THROUGHOUT THE
COMMUNITY ABOUT THE FUTURE. BUT
WE HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THE
PRESENT. AS WE NOTED IN THE IT
WAS NOTED IN THE AGENDA A RECENT
SURVEY INDICATES THAT NEARLY ONE
FIFTH OF THE WORK FORCE IS GONE
SINCEMARCH TWENTY TWENTY. AND
WE HAVE BEEN ON ABLE TO REPLACE
THIS WORKFORCE THERE ARE LOTS OF
POSSIBLE REASONS BUT WHEN THERE
ARE SIGNS IN EVERY WINDOW
OFFERING SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER
HOURLY WAGES. IN FOR WORK THAT
IS LESS DEMANDING THE DIRECT
SUPPORT WORK IT'S PRETTY EASY TO
ASSUME THAT WAGES IS A BIG
REASON PEOPLE ARE LEAVING. THE
PROBLEM IS THAT WE CAN'T
COMPENSATE I JUST SIMPLY RAISING
WAGES WHICH IS WHY WE NEED
INCREASED RATES NOW BECAUSE THAT
MONEY WILL GO STRAIGHT. TO WAGES
FOR DIRECT SUPPORT PROFESSIONALS
AND WE ARE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE LEGISLATURE
COMMITTEE STAFF TO MAKE SURE
PROVIDERS ARE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
INCREASING WAGES. WHEN THAT
MONEY SHOULD ARRIVE. MOST
CRITICALLY I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THE IMPACT OF THE WORK FORCE
SHORTAGE THE BURDEN. IS BEING
SHOULDERED BY INDIVIDUALS WITH
IDEA THEIR FAMILIES AS A VERY
QUICK SNAPSHOT BOTH THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIA'S BOARD PRESIDENT. IN
PAST PRESIDENT HAVE THEIR ADULT
CHILDREN MOVING OUT OF THEIR
INDEPENDENT LIVING IN BACK IN
WITH THEM AS PARENTS BECAUSE
THERE ARE NO STAFF TO SUPPORT
THEM. AND TRAGICALLY ALSO LOSING
SEXUALLY HOUSING OTHER WAIVER AS
A RESULT OF MOVING OUT OF THEIR
INDEPENDENT LIVING. WE CANNOT
WAIT FOR THE RIGHT STUDY
IMPLEMENTATION TO TRICKLE OUT
THE NEXT FOUR YEARS THE NEED IS
URGENT WHICH IS WHY WE ARE
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL THAT THE
SENATE INCLUDING THIS COMMITTEE
SENATE PRO TEM ACT AND BUDGET
SURE SKINNER. RECENTLY INCLUDED
IN THEIR BUDGET PLAN HE WON YOUR
ACCELERATION OF THE RATE MODEL
IMPLEMENTATION- THE RECENTLY
RELEASED SENATE BUDGET PLAN WE
ARE VERY VERY GRATEFUL FOR THAT
THANK YOU WE ARE HOPEFUL. THAT
THE SENATE PRIORITY IN AS A
BUDGET REQUEST ON THE OTHER SIDE
BY SOME OF THE- CHEER ARAMBULA.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AND
GOVERNOR WILL COME TOGETHER TO
EASE THIS TREMENDOUSLY
CHALLENGING TIME FOR THE I. D.
COMMUNITY. WE BELIEVE THAT BY
ACCELERATING THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE RATE STUDY BY ONE YEAR AS
A ONE TIME INVESTMENT REALLY FOR
THIS YEAR. AND ALSO ACCELERATING
THE QUALITY OUTCOMES BASED
REQUIREMENTS SO WE CAN BEGIN TO
AGGRESSIVELY COMPETE. FOR
WORKERS. WE ALSO DON'T WANT TO
END UP IN THE SAME SITUATION IN
JUST A FEW YEARS TIME WHERE WE
ARE TREMENDOUSLY UNDERFUNDED
AGAIN WHICH IS WHY. WE ALSO SEE
THE NEED FOR A REGULAR UPDATING
OF THE RATE MODELS AND
SUBSEQUENTLY THE RATES AND WE
ARGUE AN EXTRA. GRATEFUL TO THE
SENATE FOR ALSO INCLUDING THIS
PROPOSAL IN THE SENATE BUDGET.
FINALLY WE HAVE CHANGED AS A
COMMUNITY SINCE THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN TWO YEARS AGO AND THE RATE
STUDY ANALYZED TO PREPAY
INTERMIXED SYSTEM SUPPORTS AND
SERVICES AND WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE IS A NEED. FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO REQUEST AN
ADDENDUM TO THE RATE STUDY THAT
BRINGS NEEDED UPDATES TO RATE
MODELS ELIGIBLE SERVICES AND
BILLING METHODS. THIS TOO WE
HAVE CERTAIN ESTIMATED TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERATION. WE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. FOR
INCLUDING THESE PRIORITIES IN
THE SENATE BUDGET PLAN. THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY I'M HAPPY TO
PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION
ANSWERING QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
FOR MUCH- MISTER LINDSEY YEAH WE
ARE. WE ARE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
BEING ABLE TO DO THIS AND WE
CERTAINLY UNDERSTAND THAT-
WORKFORCE AND WORKFORCE ISSUES
HAVE BEEN A MAJOR IMPACT COMING
OF THE PANDEMIC. AND IF YOU
DON'T IF YOU DON'T PAY PEOPLE AS
MUCH AS THEIR HEARTS MIGHT BE
BIG AND GOOD I IT'S HARD TO STAY
IF YOU CAN'T PAY YOUR BILLS SO-
THIS IS CERTAINLY BEEN A
PRIORITY TO BE ABLE TO INCREASE
WAGES. ANNA AND ALSO TO BE ABLE
TO HAVE. A IT IT IT DOES NOT GET
IN THIS SITUATION AGAIN SO THAT
WE KEEP OUR EYE ON CONTINUING TO
FIND AND HAVE- ACCELERATORS WHEN
AND WHERE. IS NEEDED- SO. WE'RE
WERE HAPPY YOUR WE'RE HAPPY
YOU'RE HAPPY- M. AND WE REALLY
HOPE THIS IS GONNA GO ALONG WAY.
TO IMPROVING CARE FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS- OKAY. I
THINK THAT BRINGS US TO THE END.
OF OUR OF OUR HEARING TODAY WE
THANK EVERYBODY FOR THEIR
PARTICIPATION AND THE DEPARTMENT
FOR- THERE APRIL SPRING LETTERS
IN THE WORK THAT THEY'VE DONE.
TO THE L. A. O. AND- DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AND NOW WE WOULD SEE IF
THERE ARE ANYBODY HERE TO
PROVIDE ANY COMMENTS PUBLIC
COMMENTS. OKAY AND WE DO HAVE
ONE PERSON HERE IN PERSON SO
WOULD INVITE YOU TO THE
MICROPHONE. WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS AMY
WESTLING AND I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES WE
REPRESENT ALL THE STATE'S TWENTY
ONE REGIONAL CENTERS WHO
COLLECTIVELY ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND BOWLS WITH
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES I NEED WON THE
DIVISION OF COMMUNITY ASSISTANCE
AND RESOLUTION I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO SAY THAT REGIONAL CENTERS
UNDERSTAND THE ONLY WAY THAT OUR
WORK IS POSSIBLE IS THROUGH
COLLAB RELATIONSHIP. PEOPLE FOR
FAMILY. REGIONAL CENTER SOME
ISSUE DENIAL. QUESTS OR FOR
ELIGIBILITY BUT THEY DO SO ONLY
WHEN THEY BELIEVE THEY HAVE NO
LEGAL AUTHORITY TO GRANT THE
REQUEST. WE APPRECIATE THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSAL- THAT WILL
ENHANCE THE ABILITY TO ADDRESS
DISAGREEMENTS WHILE MAINTAINING
OR STRENGTHENING THE
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN REGIONAL
CENTERS IN THE PEOPLE THEY SERVE
AND ESPECIALLY THE CRITICAL
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN THE
SERVICE COORDINATORS AND THE
FAMILIES THAT THEY SUPPORT.
SUPPORT THE OPPOSE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE INCLUDING RELATING TO
LIMITING THE ROLE OF COUNSEL AND
BELIEVE IT PRESENTS A THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO MODERNIZING THE
REGIONAL CENTER APPEALS PROCESS
. IN TERMS OF ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE WITH THE DETAILS IN THE TVO
THE FIRST AND I BELIEVE MISTER
TREVECCA SPOKE TO USE AROUND THE
TIMELINE FOR IMPLEMENTATION THIS
IS A LOT OF CHANGE AND WE AGREE
THAT THE PROCESS FOR CHANGE
NEEDS TO BE. A STAGED ROLLOUT
THAT'S THOUGHTFUL SO THAT PEOPLE
DON'T FIND THEMSELVES CAUGHT
BETWEEN TWO SYSTEMS WHAT WE'RE
DOING TODAY AND WHAT WE
ANTICIPATE DOING IN THE FUTURE.
AND I CAN'T KNOW THAT THERE WILL
BE REGIONAL CENTER STAFF
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH
IMPLEMENTING THESE CHANGES AND
WE JUST ASK THAT AS THE PROCESS
CONTINUES THERE BE CONSIDERATION
TO ENSURING REGIONAL CENTERS
HAVE ADEQUATE STAFF TO MEET
THESE NEW DEMANDS. PIVOTING
QUICKLY TO ISSUE FIVE. WE AGREE
WITH- THE LETTERMAN COALITION
AND ARE PROUD MEMBERS OF THE
WOMEN COALITION- AND MR
LINDSEY'S PRESENTATIONS THAT
THERE ARE REALLY TWO ISSUES THE
FIRST IS A SHORT TERM FIX. HELLO
RIGHT STUDY ACCELERATION WE'RE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT THIS IS AN
ORGANIZATION AS WELL BECAUSE WE
WANT PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO GET
BACK TO IN PERSON SERVICES AND
TO RECEIVE THE SUPPORTS THEY
NEED TO BE SUCCESSFUL THE SECOND
IS A LONG TERM SOLUTION WHICH IS
AS YOU SAID- CARE EGGMAN TO
ENSURE THAT WE DON'T END UP BACK
HERE- SO THAT WE DON'T ALLOW THE
SYSTEM TO FALL INTO DISREPAIR
AND THIS IS PROBABLY THE MORE
IMPORTANT OF THE TWO PROPOSALS
IN FRONT OF YOU. BECAUSE THIS
SYSTEM. DESERVE STABILITY IN THE
PEOPLE THAT IT SERVES NEED AND
DESERVE STABILITY. I WOULD JUST
NOTE THAT- OUR CAT AS WELL AS AS
HE ARE YOU CALIFORNIA ALSO HAVE
A PARALLEL PROPOSAL RELATED TO
THIS- THAT WOULD REQUIRE REGULAR
UPDATES TO THE WAY THAT REGIONAL
CENTERS ARE BUDGETED FOR
CRITICAL SERVICE COORDINATION
AND OTHER STAFF. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
I SEE NOBODY ELSE IN THIS
HEARING ROOM WOULD GO TO THE
PHONE LINES MODERATOR ARE YOU
THERE. DO WE HAVE ANY COLORS.
YES GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
ON YOUR PHONE. AND FIRST WE'LL
GO TO LINE NINETY FIVE. GO AHEAD
PLEASE HANDS JUST A MOMENT. YES
I'M OPEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
CALLER. I NINETY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WE'LL GO TO LINE NINETY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE SEVENTY FIVE. SURE YES
PLEASE. I DON'T CARE MEMBERS.
OTHER SINGULAR MAN MEMBERS ANY
TODAY THIS IS ROBERT HARRISON B.
HAVE VASTLY I USED CALIFORNIA
PROUD TO UP SUPPORT I AM FIVE
BANDS AND THE ADDITIONAL COMMENT
BY. HI AMY WESLEY- REGARDING OUT
THE OTHER PART OF THE FACTS ALSO
INCOME FOR AS KNOW THAT BY NOW
WHEN. PEOPLE ARE. TO- YEAH IN
PERSON SERVE. BUSINESS TO
GETTING ALL SERVICES SO. I YES
PLEASE DON'T GO THREE IN EITHER
THE ONE OR THE OR ONE AFTER THIS
MONTH. HI DEBBIE WILL BE THE ON
THE ON THE PER IS TRYING TO GET
THEM TO COME BACK TO WORK WHEN
WITHOUT ANY MONEY WELL. IT THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR MUCH YOU'RE
CALM WILL TOOL FOR UP WITH A
THANK YOU A CALLER PLEASE. THANK
ONE FORTY FOUR PLEASE AHEAD. HE
MADE. THANK RIGHT NOW. HELLO
HELLO HELLO YES GO AHEAD PLEASE
. THE NUMBER EIGHT SB PROGRAM AS
A MODEL SOMEONE WILL GAMBLE ID
THE WON'T SPEND YOUR THAT YOUR
MY MATH FORMALLY FOR IN THE
WORLD. YES YEP WE GAMBLE I HE IT
THEY THEY THEN NINETY EIGHT OFF
THEIR- EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT YES
NUMBER. ZERO THAT WE ARE NOT.
YES SONORA MEXICO PLEASE. WHEN
ARE YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
THIS IS MARC BY NOT AS A
REGIONAL CENTER CLIENT AND ALL
THE CREDIT OF THE VOICES.
CALLING SUPPORT BRUSH IN THE
HEARING FISH. I WE ARE WITH WHAT
WE'RE FORWARD HEALTH CANADA EVEN
STRENGTHENS MORE WORD QUESTION
MONEY I ADDITIONAL RIGHT HOW.
I'M I WOULD WILL AS YOU WOULD
THAT ARE AT YOUR LAST YEAR
SENATOR EGGMAN THAT WE WOULD
HAVE IT I HEAR ABOUT SELF
DETERMINATION FOR HE CONTINUES
TO BE GREAT BARRIERS AND WE
REALLY BELIEVE THAT THAT THE
SENATE TO HELP FIVE I MEAN AT. I
FOR BREAKING THE BARRIERS ALSO
WANTED JUST WENT OUT THAT EQUITY
STILL A MAJOR- ISSUE- YOU TO GET
YOUR MAJOR ISSUES AND WE REALLY
TO BE FOCUSING OUR TIME ON THOSE
THE FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
OTHERS. SO- YOU HOPE THAT WE CAN
CAN EXPAND WHAT ARE CONCERNS ARE
IN THE COMING MONTHS AS YOUR
COMMITTEE THINKING TO HAPPEN A
LOT ABOUT OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
OKAY COMMENTED FOR STD TEN
NINETY TWO HELLO. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THE NEXT COLOR PLEASE
. NINE ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. STOCKS LONGER ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
LIVING NETWORK COMMENTING ON THE
ISSUE FIVE WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
CELEBRATING THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE PDS RATE STUDY WHICH WILL
HELP ALLEVIATE WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES AND CASELOAD ISSUES TO
MAXIMIZE THE IMPACT OF THE
ACCELERATION WE ALSO SUPPORT
ENSURING INCREASES ARE TARGETED
TO DIRECT CARE WORKERS.
ADDITIONALLY WE LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING TO RESOLVE RELATED
ISSUES AROUND INDEPENDENT LIVING
SERVICES RATE I LEFT THE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT SERVICE
THAT CONSUMERS HOPE TO LIVE ON
THEIR OWN AND THE STATE MUST
COME INTO COMPLIANCE WITH AGE
DBS THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH COLOR PLEASE. AND WHAT. ONE
S. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT CHAIR
THIS VERY GOOD FROM THE
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY SERVICES
THIRTY CALLING TODAY TO OUR FOR
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE AS WELL AS
PROUD MEMBERS LIMON COLO WE
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS ON THIS ISSUE
WITH AMY WESLEY FROM ARCA
INITIALING THE WAS ON THE PANEL
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE SENATE
ATTENTION TO THIS CRITICAL ISSUE
FOR THE IMMEDIATE. FUTURE OF OUR
SYSTEM. THANK TO RAMBLE AS WELL
THANKS FOR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLOR PLEASE. NINE ONE TWENTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD- GETTING ME YES
- I WILL TELL THEM THAT I'M A
MOTHER OF THREE- CHAO WHAT AT
THE MOMENT THAT THE CDM CARE
SUPPORT THEY ARE SB FAN. WITH
ANY CHANGE I BELIEVE I HERE TO
SUPPORT AND AMERICAN IT'S- THE
PREVIOUS SO BEING AN E. I DON'T
KNOW WHY. AT BODIES ARE NOT DAY
CAN THAT IS YEAH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEXICO
PLEASE. ONE ONE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE AHEAD. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIRMAN INSTRUMENT OF
GÓMEZ FROM A FATHER THAT
INDIVIDUAL SURVIVAL REGIONAL
CENTER SYSTEM AND I'M ALSO GONNA
BE AT THE INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVES. IN THE SUPPORT
OF THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
THAT IT'S BEEN INTRODUCED BY THE
DEPARTMENT AND ALSO ENCOURAGE
THE COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
THAT WERE MADE BY BOTH OF THE
INDIVIDUALS FROM THE ASSEMBLY
RIGHT CALIFORNIA WHO TESTIFIED
TODAY. AND AS WELL THE COURAGE
TO ADMIT ENSURE PLEASE KEEP
INCLUDING AGENDA ITEMS THAT
DISCUSS THE DISPARITIES IN
ACCESS AND DISSEMINATION OF
SERVICES WITHIN THE SYSTEM THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANKS PLEASE. BY ONE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN I.
NUMBER ABOUT THIS ON A THE SOME
OF MY WHEN YOU CAN. THERE ARE
NONE DISH. IF THEY DON'T THE
PENINSULA PUBLIC DOWN TOOLS BE
COMPLAINTS- FROM EVIL. BUT I
KNEW THAT IN THE GROUND YOU
WOULD BE HARD BUT IF YOU WANT
FROM FROM THE FIGURE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN I STARTED
THE NUMBER THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
YEAH MY MOTHER. ELEVEN DECEMBER
YOUR- BUT ALLOWED THE STUFF. YOU
KNOW MULLIN CAN'T OFF AT SEVEN
ELEVEN BUT THAT IS OPEN TO
ANYONE PROBABLY SIX THREE EIGHT
THAT'S WONDERFUL OKAY LET ME
BODIES IS LIKE I KNOW YOU AND IN. THE BOOK. AND I WILL I WILL BE
A GUEST YOU WAS NOT ENOUGH FOR
ME OF MOST I'M- THAT WE'LL BE
LIKE YOUR I AM. BECAUSE WHEN.
BACK IN. THIS IS. NEXT COURT.
WHEN WE THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI I'M KEVIN PERRANCE OF
THE BILL TRY BY REGIONAL CENTER
. AND WE SUPPORT THE PDF- THE
TRAILER BILL LIKE. ON REGIONAL
ECONOMIC WE ARE. WE PERSONALLY
EXPERIENCE THE IMBALANCE. AND IN
ADDITION WE SUPPORT INCREASING
CLEAN WAY TO RESTORE WORKERS
FOSTERING SERVICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANKS
CURRENT PLEASE I AM BLIND
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS WENDY- FORTY NINE COLLEEN
FROM A JOINT AT THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION THAT SERVES OVER
SEVEN HUNDRED I INDIVIDUALS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT THE SENATE SUCH A
PRIORITY OF ACCELERATING AND
REGULATING OF FEEDING THE RATE
STUDY TO IMPROVE WAGES FOR OUR
WORKFORCE. ENCOURAGE THAT THE-
CALIFORNIANS. WELL ON ACCESS THE
NECESSARY SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALL
MAYBE FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
KATHERINE HEDGES- AMERICA SIX
ALL FABRICATED AND I WAS
ACTUALLY UNITED MISSIONS THE
REGIONAL CENTER AND THERE IS NO
WAY I COULD NAVIGATE THE FAIR
HEARING PROCESS. I UNDERSTAND
YOU PROBABLY WON'T HELP ME TO
PASS THESE CHANGES THANK I
SUPPORT THE OTHER HALF THE
ARTISTIC COMMUNITY THAT IT WILL
BENEFIT THAT ARE A FAIR HEARING-
IS FOR. HOW TO DIRECTOR CALL
PEOPLE ALL OF THEM. IT'S VERY
NECESSARY I AM SO GLAD THAT THE
STATE IS CONSIDERING INCLUDING
IN THE BUDGET THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE THANKS FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
CALLED BEAR I AM A SERVICE
PROVIDER IN DOWN THE TAIL COUNTY
AND MY GRANDFATHER. SERVED IN
THE SENATE AND THE SEVEN SEAT
MATE WITH- SENATOR PATRICK. HE
VOTED FOR AND SIGNED THEM HELP
DROP THEIR GERMAN ACT. AND I
WOULD URGE YOU AS YOU'LL PLEASE
SUPPORT THE ACCELERATION OF
MODERNIZATION OF THE FUNDING FOR
REGIONAL CENTERS AND-
IMPLEMENTING A RATE STUDY TUTOR.
THE YOU TO FULFILL HIS PROMISE
HE MADE THAT THAT CITIZENS OF
CALIFORNIA WITH DISABILITIES
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE NINE ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. YES AM A
FIGHTER WHAT ARE THE MCCARRON OF
A CONSUMER FONG AND THEN WITH
THE HELP CENTER AND ACROSS IT SB
FOR NINETY SEVEN WITHOUT ANY
OTHER THINGS THAT. WE NEED TO
HELP OUR CHILDREN ARE IN
GREATEST DOWNEY. WE NEED FOR
FEEDBACK FOR DO YOU HAVE WE NO
BETTER HOW ABOUT THE APPLE RIGHT
NOW THE FIELD. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CURRENT. THANK THREE AHEAD
. HELLO OUT OF HERE THIS IS PAT
HORNBECK- I AM PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE ARK OF
CALIFORNIA. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
AND JOSEPH'S MOM AND YES IT HAS.
BEEN LIVING IN HIS OWN APARTMENT
HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO. BUT
SUPPORTED LIVING. THIS AS THAT
KOBE HIT HARD WITH. AND IT MADE
IT VERY DIFFICULT TO KEEP STAFF
SO I AM SPEAKING TO SUPPORT THE
BUDGET PRIORITIES. THAT ARE PUT
FORTH HERE ACCELERATING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEEDIEST
RATE FANNIE AND I ALSO. WANT TO
STRESS THAT THE REGULAR UPDATES
ARE GOING TO BE NEED. FUTURE
OKAY YES THEY WERE AND TO BEGIN
WITH BECAUSE WE WERE TO. THAT WE
WEREN'T UP WITH THE COST OF
LIVING'S AND THE AND THE COST OF
SERVICES AND THE COST OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE WERE RUNNING.
SO THE REGULAR UPDATES THAT WILL
FOLLOW THIS. ON AN ANNUAL BASIS
IS SOMETHING WE REALLY NEED TO
CONSIDER AS WELL- ALSO. WE DID
THAT. YEAH TWENTY EIGHT IN AND
WE HAVE SET HAD VERY HARD WITH
KOBE AND THE LOSS OF MANY MANY
MANY OTHER STAFF- UNTIL I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO- MAKE SURE THAT
THE- TARGETED UPDATES ARE
ADDRESSING AGES IT ALL HAS
SUFFER THROUGH AND- I DON'T
POINT OUT. THAT HE- THE MONEY
THAT ARE GOING TO BE GOING
FORWARD ARE GOING TO BE DIRECTED
TO DIRECT SUPPORT STAFF- WE HAVE
NOT BEEN PAYING THEM WELL ENOUGH
AND WE ALL KNOW HOW HARD IS IT
EMILY MEMBERS ACROSS THE STATE
THERE ARE TWENTY TWO CHAPTERS
ARE TAKING UP THE SLACK AND
THERE'S ONLY FAR THAT- IF I.
SENATE AND THE ASSEMBLY FOR MAKE
. WITH I. B. I'M- THANK YOU MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE NINE ONE
SEVEN EIGHT TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS ALLISON FOR DEBT
WITH WE FIND OUR FAMILY SERVICES
SERVE TWENTY THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILY MEMBERS
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND AFFORDABLE
LAMBING COALITION WE'RE GOING TO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL IN ISSUE
FIVE TO ACCELERATE THE RATE
STUDY IMPLEMENTATION. WE WANT TO
THANK TONI ATKINS NANCY SKINNER
AND SUSAN EGGMAN FROM THIS
PROPOSAL AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE FULL TESTIMONY BY MR LINDSAY
THAT YOU HEARD EARLIER WE ARE IN
FULL AGREEMENT THAT. CRITICAL
SHORTAGE OF DIRECT SERVICE
PROFESSIONALS IN PARTICULAR IS
DRIVEN BY A NEED FOR INCREASED
WAGES. ARE AND THAT THE ID
SYSTEM CAPACITY TO PROVIDE
SERVICES AND SUPPORT ACROSS
CALIFORNIA TO THOSE WHO NEED
THEM IS BEING ACTIVELY REDUCED
IN A DOCTOR BY THE IT HELLO.
BOTH REGION ALONE IT TO HIRE
THIRTY FOUR. IF WE WERE TO FIX
THE- OUR FULL HOW TO PASS- THE
CAPACITY COULD NEEDS BE A DRUG
THROUGH THE PROPOSALS IT'S VERGE
NEEDED. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU FOR MUCH
THANKS CALLER PLEASE. THANK ONE
PLEASE AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
NOW AND I WERE WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. WHAT YOU SERVICE
PROVIDER THAT PROVIDE- AVIATOR
CENTER CALIFORNIA'S BY CARE AND
RIGHT THE- SERVICES DAYCARE
PERSONAL WITHIN THEIR BEHAVIOR
CORRECTIVE ACTION. WE FULLY
SUPPORT THE RATE THAT THE
ACCELERATION ISSUE FIVE. THIS
WILL HELP OUR ORGANIZATION AND
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE ARE YOU
SUPPORT THE FAMILY THAT
DEFINITELY NEED OUR SERVICES. HE
TO THE CURRENT AND THE POSSIBLE
MEDIAN RIGHT TO CHALLENGES
RETAIN STAFF AND HIRE STAFF- IN
THE FAMILY THAT THE BETTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TAX COLOR PLEASE I AM. ONE FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
AFTERNOON MADAM. MY IS ROBIN
MILLER I'M A THREE IF MEN FOR
EARLY INTERVENTION SERVICES FOR
OUR MOST VULNERABLE CITIZENS
BIRTH TO THREE YEARS OF AGE. I
COMPLETELY SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL
IN THE BUDGET PRIORITIES- TO
ACCELERATE THE RATE MODEL.
IMPLEMENTATION BY A YEAR IT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO BRING UP THE WORK FORCE
SHORTAGE WE HAVE TO HAVE
QUALIFIED PERSONNEL TO SERVE OUR
LITTLES AND THEIR FAMILIES THAT
ARE JUST ENTERING THE SYSTEM.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE SENATE-
PRO PAN TONI ATKINS BUDGET
COMMITTEE CHAIR NANCY SKINNER
AND YOURSELF FOR ALL THE WORK
YOU'VE DONE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE.
I WANT TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NINE NINE MY NAME IS
WATER CANNELLA IN ONE SECOND
BEING ABOUT FIFTEEN. MILES FROM
NOW UNTIL NEXT. BERMAN IS A YOU
KNOW AND BEST I THINK HE CAN
NINETY THE WATER. WITHOUT CAN'T
BECAUSE THEM ON THE- AND I THINK
THE THING NEEDED FOR NINETY
BACKING AND IF THERE. THANK YOU
MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE I AM ONE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
MOTIVATED BY THEIR IBM FROM OR
YOU KNOW SPENCER. IN MY- FROM
INTERPOL GET LAZY TEN NINETY
TWO. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANKS CALLER PLEASE NINE
FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HELLO MY NAME IS LIZ. I'M SORRY
. PLEASE YES- MY NAME IS LINDA
FLOOR- EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
DAIRY ANKH AND NAPA CALIFORNIA-
WE SUPPORT PEOPLE OF
INDIVIDUALS- BUT IN THEIR OWN
HOMES IN FIVE COUNTIES HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- I AM A MEMBER OF THE
WOMEN'S COALITION AND ALSO ON
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
NATIONAL SOCIO OF AND THAT.
POLICE THAT BECAUSE I'M AWAY
THAT- THIS WORKFORCE PRICE THE
PROVIDERS OF SERVICE FACES
NATIONAL NOT ONLY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- SO. TODAY I WANT TO
THE WORD OF JORDAN THE AND OF
AMY WESTLING- I FURTHER WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT POINTS ON ISSUE
NUMBER FIVE. CELEBRATION OF THE
GREAT STUDY- IT'S IMPERATIVE-
THAT THIS EXPLORATION OCCUR
BECAUSE WE'RE ALREADY FAR BEHIND
IN THE FUNDING FOR THE WORK THAT
WE DO AND IN DOING SO EXIT YOU
KNOW EXHILARATING. ADDITION OF
THIS RATE STUDY THERE'S A PLACE
CALIFORNIA IN THE LEAD
NATIONWIDE SHOWING SHOWING THE
COUNTRY ACTS- SO WE'RE DOING ALL
WE CAN TO MILLION RATE THE
WORKFORCE CHALLENGES SAFE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS ARE CONTRARY AND I'M CALLING
FROM STOCKTON CALIFORNIA I HAVE
A GRANDSON THAT IS THE CLIENT OF
THE VALLEY MOUNTAIN REGIONAL
CENTER I SUPPORT SB TEN NINETY
TWO AS WRITTEN BY SENATOR WOULD
FOLLOW WITHOUT ANY CHANGES
BECAUSE I THINK WE GIVE I NEED
TO DEMAND EQUALITY AND EQUITY IN
THAT SITUATION. EVEN WITHOUT
LAWYERS ON BOTH SIDES WE CENTERS
VERSUS PARENTS THE REGIONAL
CENTERS WILL STILL HAVE THE
UPPER HAND I AM ALSO VERY
DISAPPOINTED THAT DISPARITIES
WERE NOT PART OF THIS AGENDA.
DISPARITIES ARE ALIVE AND WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ITS COLOR PLEASE. NINE ONE
TWENTY THREE GO AHEAD. HELLO GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO YES HELLO
YES ONE OF. THE NUMBER OF MONEY
ON A MACBOOK YOUR FOR YOUR- FOR
YOU LITTLE THE NIGHT OF FEBRUARY
YOU HAVEN'T PAID OFF BANK OF NEW
YORK I MEAN FOR THE COVETED
OTHER CONTAMINANTS ACETYL ON NEW
YORK IN THE LOCAL MALL. BUT I
GOT A VISA. A NUMBER. ONE OF THE
BENEFITS FOR YOU BUT I CANNOT
FROM ANOTHER AND BEYOND. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AN I AM NOT
A TIMING WHO HOLD ON A SEC I
HAVE NOT TIMING BEAT BECAUSE OR
HEARINGS BIT SHORTER BUT I DO
NEED TO GET TO KNOW COMMITTEE
SOMEONE ASKED PEOPLE THIRTY
SECONDS AND I WILL ALSO NOTE
PEOPLE ARE CALLING ABOUT SONORA
TACOS SB TEN NINETY TWO THAT IS
NOT ON THE AGENDA TODAY BUT WE
DO KNOW THAT IT'S HAS TO DO ALSO
WITH THE FAIR HEARING PROCESS-
SO IF YOU'RE CALLING ABOUT SB
TEN NINETY TWO THAT IS NOT WE
ARE NOT HEARING THAT TODAY- WE
ARE RESPONDING TO THE- TO THE
DEPARTMENTS- APRIL LETTERS FOR
CHANGE. AND GOING FORWARD LET'S
HAVE THAT THIRTY SECONDS ON THE
LINE MAY HAVE TO A RECESS WHERE
I HAVE TO GO PERCENT ANOTHER
BILL IN IN ANOTHER COMMITTEE-
BUT NEXT COLOR PLEASE. NINE ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
OKAY LINE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
IF YOU NO LONGER WISH TO SPEAK
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AGAIN
TO REMOVE YOURSELF FROM THE LINE
. LINE ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS ANDREA
WELLS AND I'M CALLING FROM
COPART HOW WE SERVE ABOUT EIGHT
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL AND DISABILITIES
AND THEIR FAMILIES INSEMINATING
L. LA IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY. I
SUPPORT THE SENATE. BUDGET PARTY
OF EXHILARATING AND REGULARLY
UPDATING THE RATE STEADY THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE I
ONE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS SAAD IS ANJANA ON
ISSUE FIVE I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA. AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF INTEGRATED
RESOURCES INSTITUTE A NONPROFIT
FOCUSED ON PROVIDING EMPLOYMENT
SERVICES TO PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. MIGHT EVEN BE A
RECEIPT ON PRESIDENT HIRING
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND JOB
AND CAREER THAT THEY'RE CHOOSING
IT'S BEEN WONDERFUL HOWEVER THE
WORK FORCE SHORTAGE HAS GREATLY
IMPACTED THE SUCCESS OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS IN THE WORKPLACE. IN
ADDITION TO DELAY THE START OF
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE INTERESTED
IN EMPLOYMENT. IT FEEL GUILTY
FOR STUDENTS AND TERRIBLE FOR
STUDENTS TRANSITION. INTO ADULT
THANK YOU. NOTE FOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR CALL TODAY
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINE ONE
THIRD. PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YES HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES. HI MY NAME
OF MY MEDICAL MY GUY AND I AM A
MODERATE ENOUGH AND BY ANY WHO
SHARE BY THE BAND AND I AM
CALLING TODAY FOR THE FIRE TO
THAT HAPPENED NOT BEING HEARD IS
YEAR HE KNOWS BEFORE THAT FOR
HEARING THAT. YOU HAVE WE NEED
TO TALK. ABOUT THAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT COLOR
PLEASE I. WON NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES THE MONEY
IN THE FABIAN. YOUR I WILL BE
OLD DAUGHTER DECLINED OF A VERY
CENTER AND I WAS TO USE TOPIC OF
THIS PARTY ON THAT HERE TO
SUPPORT SENATE BILL DOUBLING
THEIR THE TEN NINETY TWO WE ANY
CHANGES THANK THANK. IT'S COLOR
. THREE YES GO AHEAD. HELLO-
WILL FALL INTO SPECIAL MEASURES
DURING GOING TO BE THE JUST. AND
ALL THE OF ARE CHILL GO TO.
WITH- THE LACK OF REPRESENTATION
THE WITH THE PMR SEASON. FOLLOW
AREAS THAT THEY TO FACE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE THANK HERE. YOU
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MOBILE
PHONE MY TO LOW NAY IT MAY. SO
AS- COULD AVAILABILITY STERN
SAYING BUSINESS LEADERS NINTENDO
THAT. ARE WORKING THERE THERE'S
A I PHONE DO OF BOTH THE COMPANY
. HELD NAY WOULD. I DIDN'T. USE.
BUT I USED FOR- A THE CURRENT HE
SAID. WE CAN. IT IS HELLO. YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CALLER
PLEASE BY ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE
GO. HI MY NAME IS MATT LAUER
FROM THE ARGUS INDIEGOGO WE
SERVE ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL
AND DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY. THANKS FOR
THE EXPRESS OUR FULL SUPPORT IN
APPRECIATION FOR ISSUE FIVE AND
WE TRULY NEED THIS FUNDING TO
IMPROVE EMPLOYEE RECRUITMENT AND
RETENTION OF OUR WORKFORCE THANK
YOU. VERY MUCH THANKS CALLER
PLEASE SIGN HERE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS
GABRIELLE BARCA I AM THE OLDER
BROTHER OF TWO LINES ON THE
REGIONAL CENTER. AND I'M CALL
SUPPORT OF- PALATIAL ONE. IN
ORDER TO REMOVE THE- POWER OF
REGIONAL CENTERS TO ATTEND
IMPARTIAL HEARINGS WITH LAWYERS
OR ATTORNEYS- THAT PROVIDES AN
UNFAIR ADVANTAGE TO THEM OVER
THE- INSTAGRAMMING MEMBERS AND
CLIENTS ARE TRYING TO PRESENT
THEMSELVES IN THAT IMPARTIAL
HEARING THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT COLOR PLACE. ENTER ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOW MANY FROM
YOUR MODEM NINE OUR PHONE WITH
AND YOU DIDN'T HAVE AREA THAT
YOU SPACE I THINK IT'LL SEND.
THANK YOU FOR IT HE SAID. TWO
WITHOUT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MICHAEL CAN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THAT DIDN'T MY IS RICK
ADAMS WITH THAT WE OF ONE
COUNTY- WE'RE CALLING SICK OF
ISSUE FIVE. ORGANIZATIONS ABOUT
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENT
THIS EVERYDAY WE A CAREER WERE
CURRENTLY FIFTY STAFF. CONSIST
OF AND THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO CHANGE
THINGS HERE RIGHT NOW SO WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT WITH
RIGHT NOW- ACCELERATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISS COLOR PLEASE
NINE NINE. GO AHEAD. I YES WE
CAN. I THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
UP WELL I'M I'M NOT- FAMILIES
ARE IN MENDING DELAY AND I- LIKE
THAT IDEA SPOKE FROM- YOUR
DEMOING AND- BUT APPLE YEAH WELL
IF YOU IN. CORRECT AND NOT I'M
GONNA PHONES THAT ARE NOT YEAH
WELL YOU BE. X. PM WELL AS A-
INSOMNIA YOUR LOVE ON MY. EIGHT
THE END YEAH. YOU SEE THAT OKAY
FOR HIM. IT A W. NINE THE NEON
ABOUT YOU'RE NOT IN THE ONE
MOVIE FLAG IF THIS THAT.
A LITTLE SISTER AND COUSINS WHO
HAVE AUTISM AND I DON'T KNOW
WHERE ON THIS SPECIFIC CATEGORY
BUT I'M HERE TO. THE BOSTON
THIRTY. HE AMBER I'M VERY
HEARING. AND. I SUPPORT THE S.
B. TEN TEN NINETY TWO OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU OKAY
LANG TWO SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WELL YES HELLO- ARE YOU
NUMBER MANY OF OUR LOCAL. AND
ALL FOR HIDDEN UNDER HIM AFTER
LOVE THE SEE WHAT OTHER COULD BE
ON APPLE YEAH IT'S A VERY YES
SINGLE FACT. FROM BOOK THAT
AMOUNT I'M A BE WHAT HAPPENED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RETAIN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER I
REMEMBER. WELL THAT'LL BE IN THE
FENCE OF LIKE YOU I DON'T I
THINK YOU HAVE TO. HE YEP FOR
FREEDOM. THE DALLAS. THEY'RE NOT
ENTITLED. THANK YOU NEXT CALL
PLEASE LINE TWENTY ONE PLEASE.
THE NUMBERS MIGHT WATER I AM A
MUSLIM DATACENTER DURING COUNTY
- REPUBLICAN SENATE WAS THAT IN
THE EVENT OF THE IS THANK YOU
NEWS CORP AND ONE SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AB ONE. WHEN IS THE
NUMBER MY LADY IN THERE THAT A I
THINK WE'LL GET A IF YOU'RE NOT
A GOOD NIGHT A LOWER IF THEY'RE
NOT A BODY THAT IN AN IMAC PAINS
YOU WHEN ON ABOUT THE ASSIGNING
INTO THE YEAH WERE BOTH NUMBER
IF YOU IF NOT HIM BACK I THINK
IT ONLY. UP WE DON'T THEY BE.
HONESTLY THERE WAS A LOT ABOUT-
PRESERVATION THEY NEVER HELPED
ME WITH ANYTHING UNTIL NOW. AND
I WILL. HERE'S TO- AS POLICE TO
HELP US SUPPORT SB. SEVEN NINETY
TWO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
CALLER PLEASE THANK YOU TWENTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER
EIGHT YES I'M BUT MY AT A LOCAL
RENT OF THE WOMAN IT'S NOT
THERE'S SOME AND VERY VERY LARGE
ARE NOT I HAD. HE WAS ACTED AS
THAT ELEVEN STUDY THAT PICKED.
HE AMBER AND I'M THE ONE. YES
WELL YOU KNOW TOP FOR YOUR OR
FUND FUNDS YOUR FAMILY IN THE
ONE PASSED YEP WE HAVE I'M BEING
I'LL DATE SB.
AND I THINK A LOT YOU THINK I'M
ON THE PHONE BOOK A PHONY OR NOT
ELEVEN HE WENT BACK TO ON THE MY
LIFE WE IT THE ANNUAL BOTH OF
THE PEOPLE OF THE NORTH HANDS
WAS NOT BEING UP FOR YOUR AS. MY
PLEASE. WHEN IT. YES. ARE YOU
MONDAY THEY OWN UP ON THE BACK
THE LETTER ON A YOU'LL REMEMBER
A LOT LESS SEVENTIES NOT FATAL
ENABLING COMBAT. EIGHTY EIGHT
AND THE EIGHT A BALLOT IN
MULTIPLE NOT IN STOCK IN. YEAH
THANK YOU MUCH THANK PLEASE MIND
THIRTY PLACE GO AHEAD. ONE OF
FRIDAY MAY NOBODY ASKED ME THAT
. SORRY MY MOTHER THERE WILL BE
A THAT NOT LIKE YOU'RE NOT IN
THAT AND YOU WANT THAT YEAH WELL
YOUR YOUR FOR SUPPORT YES IT'D
BE S. YES- AND I THOUGHT THAT.
THE NEW YORKER THAT VERY MUCH
NAY COLOR.
REGULATE TWENTY TWENTY TWO NOT
TWENTY TWENTY THREE I'VE NEVER
SEEN CONDITIONS THIS WAY AND-
THIS IS BADLY NEEDED. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT TIME
PLEASE. NINE ONE EIGHT PM PLEASE
GO AHEAD. NINE ONE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU THIRTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I'M A
CURRENT TO REGIONAL CENTER
CLIENT THE DIRECTOR OF AN AGENCY
THAT PROVIDES SERVICES THE
TWENTY SIX HUNDRED REGIONAL
CENTER CLIENTS THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA I WANT TO THANK TONI
ATKINS NANCY SKINNER EGGMAN
PRECLUDING THIS PROPOSAL THEIR
BUDGET PRIORITIES I WANT TO VOTE
WE SUPPORT FOR THE BDS
ACCELERATED RATE INCREASE. FOR
THE PAST FEW YEARS WE'VE ONLY
RECEIVED AN AVERAGE OF 30% RATE
INCREASE- HE. I WANT EACH YEAR
AFTER. AND WORK COMP THANK TO
ABOUT ONE DAY AND EIGHTY CENTS
OUR YEAH ONLY HAVE RECEIVED
INCREASED IN. THIRTY CENTS PER
YEAR WE CANNOT UP WITH THE
CLIENT OR THE ONE SUFFERING
ALREADY STATE AGENCIES LIKE OUR
CANNOT COMPLETE HIRING AND
DIESEL RIGHT. NEED HELP EIGHT
LIKE OURS TO WORK CLINTON FAMILY
. THANKS CELEBRATING RATE AND SO
WE CAN PAY ARM APPOINTEE WEIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK. THIRTY THANK. YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GO AHEAD PLEASE.
THANK YOU FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I LONG NUMBER OF BIDS I
HAVE CLIENTS I WOULD NEVER YOU
KNOW CENTER AND I DON'T KNOW WHY
YOU'RE STILL NOT FROM A DECIDED
TO PRODUCE WITH THE HAVE A LOT
OF DISPARITIES IN THE SYSTEM I
DON'T KNOW WHY WE'RE NOT TALKING
ABOUT IS LIKE IT'S NOT A FIFTY
ANYMORE. AND WE- COME STILL
SUFFERING ME THERE STILL A LOT
OF ALLOWED THAT THOUGHT IT IS AN
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY OUR WAY
INTO BOROUGH AT B. THANK YOU
FOR. VERY MUCH CALLER PLEASE MY
ONE OH EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE I KNOW IT SHOULD IS OPEN.
NINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY I
HAD. AND ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. WELL
APARTMENT. THEY'RE NOT GONNA JIM
LANDOWNERS COUNTY. NUMBER ONE
THAT IS FOR MORE FIGURE MAN NOT
WOMAN NUMBER FOUR FIVE SEVEN OF
THEM THE PLACE AND I'M NOT UP OR
DOWN OKAY HERE'S MY NO SON OF A
**** THAT'S MORE LOCAL CRIME
HERE. IN A MONDAY MOSTLY ONE.
WELL HELLO COMMON CURRENTLY WHEN
YOU OPEN UP A FEW MOTHER THANK.
THE YOU VERY MUCH THANK COLOR
PLAY. I ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE
AHEAD. WELL I'M JUST. FAMILIAR
PROJECT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHEN I STARTED
THE NUMBER OF MONEY A LOT I
THINK THEN WE'LL SEE WHO GETS ON
FINANCES AND FRIENDS OR IF
YOU'RE NOT IN THE STOCK- ALL IF
YOU WANT OTHER FROM BEING THE
ONE UP ON YOUR UP WITH THAT IF
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT I WENT THE
NEW MOTORCYCLE FROM YOU EVEN ON
THE MOBILE THAT FOR FIVE OR
GRAPH YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK YOU.
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU FIFTY SEVEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI HI I'M MOST OF THE
V. S. TEN NINETY TWO. AND I HAVE
TO ALL NEXT YEAR IS- IN THE
REGIONAL CENTER ON I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THANK YOU YOU STOP
TALKING ABOUT THE- OF- WHAT IT.
HE WAS NOT EIGHT- WELL I MEAN
FOR YOUR THIRTY THAT'S ANOTHER
THING ONE DOLLARS ONE OF THE
THAT YEAH I DON'T PROGRAM GROUND. THANK THANK SIXTY TWO THANK GO
AHEAD. ALL UP WHEN I THOUGHT OF
IT. THE NUMBER OF UNILATERAL.
ONLY ONE OF THE BILL NINE YEAH.
IT BUT THEN I THOUGHT WHAT FINE
IF I AM YEAH THEY ALWAYS UP WE
GET A D. IT IF THEY'D YET NINE
DAYS ALL PHILOSOPHY WHAT ABOUT
IF YOU. WOULD THE NEW SANTIAGO.
THANK AND THE IN WHERE FOR MY
BODY MORE DOWN AND PUT HIM DOWN
LAST LARA LIKE ARM INCLUDE LIVE
WITH IT WILL NOT IT. HELLO
INCLUYENDO DAMS I THINK ARE.
ELEVEN PEOPLE I SUPPOSE ONE YEAH
THIS CALL ABOUT. THE YOU VERY
MUCH COLOR PLAY. I WANNA WAIT
PLEASE GO. I AM I WAKE
CAROLINA'S OPEN. THANK YOU FOR
PLEASE GO AHEAD- HUH. YES I
THINK THIS WOULD HAVE MEANT.
ANYTHING THAT WILL NOT INCLUDE
THE CORRECT AMOUNT BY UNANIMOUS
YOU. FOR IT'S IT BIG A LOT HE
WAS BADLY IF THERE WILL BE IN
THE IF MOMENT THANK THOSE IN
ABOUT THE LEGAL AND PEOPLE. THE
MINIMUM CREDIT SCORE PLEASE.
NINE TWO SEVENTY GO. THANK
HEAVENS THERE LINE IS OPEN. THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ZERO SEVEN HUNDRED MULTI LEVEL
HAVE TO FOLLOW UP WITH ME THAT I
COULD TRAVEL BUT NOT ENOUGH TO
BE THAT'S WHAT. ANOTHER INLAND
YOU OFFER YOU A LOT. OF MONEY
AND THEY DON'T KNOW THAT WOULD
THAT'LL BE FOLLOWED THEM YET-
BUT. I'LL PEOPLE DO NOT WANT
THEM TO SEE THAT APPLE YOU KNOW
SOMEONE. FAMILY THE ONE. INITIAL
GIVEN THE AT IT BECAUSE- TO THE
- THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLOR PLAY
. THANK HEAVEN FOR PLEASE GO.
BUT IT IS A VERITABLE WHAT
PASSED FOR I WANT TO YOU BRING
YOUR FOR THE FOOTBALL LAST YEAR
AND THIS YEAR OUR SUPPORT ISSUE
BY OR THE LATE BY YEAR. BOTH THE
MONEY GOING TO DIRECT CARE SO. I
KNOW. BUT IT WHY. FIGURATION
AGAIN BY FIFTY ISSUES WITH THAT
THE RATE IDEA CLOUT AND IN THE
BEND- AND A MACINNES TO PROVIDE
ON IN THE WORD UNDER FIFTY STAFF
. FIRST RATE THE RATE BY TWO
DOLLARS AN HOUR AFTER THE SOME
RELIEF- THAT BUT WE NEED MORE
AND THANK YOU MUCH FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLOR PLEASE THANK AND I. YOU'RE
NOT. GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO YES
GO AHEAD PLEASE. FROM SOMEONE
FROM THE FROM ARM THE WORLD
HELLO WE- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALLER PLEASE THANK. FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO WHEN I
MEMBER PHILADELPHIA NOTICES THE
OUTLINES OF THE NEEDS OF THE
PERSON IN THE WHOLE FIFTY IS
THERE ON CAMPUS AND- UP. WHAT BE
ABLE. A LITTLE FEEL AS IF YOU
WANT OTHER STATES EVEN HANDLED
YEAH NO PROBLEM I READY AS ARE
THERE'S A LOT AND THAT AND MUCH
OF RIGHTEOUS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TAX COURT PLEASE. THANK YOU FIVE
PLEASE I HAD. THANKS FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. OKAY TAKE A AROUND
ABOUT THE WORLD YOU KNOW AND
THEY ALL NEED HIGHEST BOND
INTEREST. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS COLOR PLEASE. NINE
SEVENTY SIX ELEVEN OPEN. WHEN I
FELT THAT MY NUMBER'S BODY
ABSOLUTELY MODEL NINETY YEAH ON
THE FACT THAT FEEDBACK OF
SEATTLE OF. I'VE BEEN THERE MANY
UP FOR YOUR BE A THIS ESTIMATED
TO BE EXAMINED BY BOTH THINGS
CRIME. IT FOR OUR PRACTICAL
ABOUT IT J. LOOKS MORE LIKE YOU
KNOW SO YEAH YOU MUST GANDALF.
IT WILL DIE IN THIS CUIDADO.
FIFTEEN I THINK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT CALL PLEASE. NINE EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE. PROMENADE FLOW ON-
WAS- BRIDGE LOCATION VENDOR
THROUGH A SINGLE WE CONSIDER-
THE PRO PROVIDER OUR MAIN FOCUS
IS HELPING INDIVIDUALS MAKE
THEIR OWN CHOICES AND BE
INDEPENDENT- OF THE PROVIDER
RATE REFORM AS- THIS WILL THOSE
WITH AND RECRUIT NEW STUFF THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY COLOR THESE
. NO ONE ELSE HERE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK OUR BUDGET SUB
THREE HEARING FOR TODAY IT CAN
GET A CHANCE TO EXPRESS YOURSELF
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO CONTACT OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF. WE'RE NOT
PUTTING OUR- S. B. TEN NINETY
TWO TODAY WE DO KNOW A LOT OF
SUPPORT FOR A MMHM THE CENTER
TACOS BILL ALSO DEALING WITH THE
- HEARINGS- AND THAT WILL BRING
A CONCLUSION TO THIS HEARING.